Previously on Movamex Unsere deutsche Sprache, für viele ist sie nicht mehr das, was sie einmal war.
Ist das schon ne Product Transition?
Irgendwie bist du da rüber geswitcht.
Aber ich halte diese ganze Motorola-Geschichte für einen totalen Fake.
Diese ganzen Last Storage-Boden.
Ich meine, what's the fucking problem, Pop-up im Präferenz zu haben, wo man sagt, da rüber abspielt.
Total overkill und hat massenhaft Feature.
Du hast, glaube ich, bei allen auch dieses Zero Setup.
Irgendwo musst du diesen Key dieser Software sagen.
Und zwar, dass jetzt, wenn du den Terminal minimierst, in den Stock rein, dass da drin weiter live geupdatet wird.
Die geht dann einfach bei Out of the Box, weil sie die richtige Ausrede-Deepation verwendet hat.
Also ich musste, auf FreeBSD musste ich irgendwie was machen.
Was heißt das? Es ging noch ohne Warning oder es wurde gewarnt?
Also der wollte einen kompletten Rewrite nochmal machen.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bum Zag Return.
Also heute reden wir Deutsch.
Das hat mich plopp gemacht.
Wie die Franzosen das auch machen. Die haben für alles...
Deutsch zu reden?
Für alles haben die einen französischen Begriff. Und wenn es noch keinen gibt, dann wird halt einer erfunden.
Ich hab das eben gar nicht mitbekriegt, dass es um unsere englischen Fachbegrifflichkeiten da geht. Auf unsere Englisch-Language-Appeal-Losage-Stuff ging.
Hat angefangen. Live in deiner Farbe, Mobile Max Nummer 72. Heute in leicht eingeschränkter Besetzung, denn Denis ist im Fnord und wir wünschen ihm dort alles Gute. Max testet derweil das Piraten-Sieger-Getränk.
Das trinkt ein Sieger.
Ja, das ist schon immer so gewesen. Und Hucke, du bist auf...
Ich trinke heute mal ein Bier. Ja, ich hatte heute zwei Flora-Power-Mate und bin noch hübelig. Und jetzt muss man ein Bierchen zum runterkommen, ist vielleicht nicht schlecht sonst. Hübelig aus dem Stuhl raus.
Ja, das gute Flensburger in der studiofreundlichen Abverpackung, auch wieder verschließbar. Tastatur schonend im Zweifelsfall.
Ach, das war der Serviervorschlag gleich, ja?
Ja, naja, das Studio Bier ist sozusagen Flensburger, weil man das halt zu machen kann.
Sehr gut. Aber hier ist ja nicht so ein Tobawo, dass man da gleich mit dem Schlimmsten rechnen muss. Vielleicht nach dem zweiten oder dritten?
Genau, dann achten wir da dann auch besser drauf. Ja, ansonsten, wir blicken zurück auf weitgehende Ereignisreiche.
Ereignislosigkeit.
Hier kommt gerade noch eine Meldung rein. Bei Heise steht, Dell steigt nicht aus seinem PC-Geschäft aus. Es wird keine Meldung bei Heise sein.
Ja, weil sie ja auch kein anderes Geschäft haben.
Na ja, das war aber, weil er hat HP auch nicht gehindert.
HP hat ein anderes Geschäft. Also zumindest meinen sie, dass sie ein anderes haben. Aber wenn Dell da jetzt aussteigt, ich meine...
Sie steigen ja nicht aus, sie steigen ja nicht aus.
Oder hat Dell auch Drucker, nee, ne?
Die hatten bestimmt auch mal Drucker. Die hatten auch mal so MP3-Player.
Ja, die haben Drucker, die haben sogar ziemlich gute Drucker. Und MP3-Player. Ja, also in vielen Büros ist auch ganz viele Dell Laser-Drucker.
Wirklich?
Die sind günstig und okay, also die sind jetzt...
Guck an.
Also von Dell gibt es auch Drucker. Dell das neue HP.
Gut, also wir halten fest, von Dell gibt es auch Drucker. Ja, aber von Dell verkaufen sie auch weiterhin PC's. Ich würde ja sagen, sie sollten irgendwie das Geld den Shareholder zurückgeben und den Aktienbesitzern, den Aktienbesitzern, Enteils-Eignern, den Anteils-Eignern sollten sie das Geld zurückgeben.
Dieses sichere Durchstöbern letztes Mal als Sendungstitel war auch wirklich gut, also ich hab das auch mal ausprobiert, das Fazialbuch auf Deutsch zu stellen, um dann...
Wie viele schöne deutsche Namen gibt's denn für den Gesichtskatalog?
Also Fratzenbuch fand ich immer eher doof.
Ich sag Fazialbuch.
Fratzenverzeichnis. Na, doch Fratzenverzeichnis.
Ich sag jetzt nicht, was ich verstanden hab.
Also wirklich Max. Dume und deine anzüglichen Wortspielereien.
Ja.
Als wär das Niveau nicht schon niedrig genug.
Niemals endenden Tweets, die einem noch Jahre später um die Ohren getweetet werden.
Na ja, Spaß ging so. Also ich mein, das war wirklich so ab... Also als die Leute aufstanden, fing die... Ich bin ja so eine eitle Sau. Ich krieg das ja immer als Notification auf mein iPhone, wenn ich irgendwo retweetet oder gefaft werde.
Gefaft?
Was war das?
Favorisiert werde.
Ah ja, wenn du favorisiert wurdest.
Wenn ich geretwittert werde... Was ist der deutsche Begriff für twittern? Zwittert.
Wenn ich...
Wiedergezwitschert werde.
Wiedergezwitschert werde oder favorisiert werde. Dann krieg ich eine iTelefon-Benachrichtigung in einem Pop-up-Fenster.
iTelefon, meinst du wohl.
Pop-up-Fenster.
Du meinst ein Aufsprungsfenster.
Das ist wirklich schwer.
Das wird heute eine lustige Sendung.
Ich denke auch, ich denke auch. Ich mach erst mal eine Mate auf.
Ja, auf jeden Fall kam das da irgendwie ziemlich viele.
Also ihr seht schon, wir lassen uns hier auch... Es ist nicht so, dass wir uns nicht auch beeinflussen lassen. David hat mal wieder hier alle Register gezogen bei dem Intro.
Großartig.
Und genau.
Hier, warte mal, da.
Und wir danken allen, die auch David per Flatter unterstützen, wie wir auch allen den danken, die uns per Flatter unterstützen. Was kommt jetzt?
Und wir danken an alle, die uns so lustiges Bildmaterial natürlich auch in den Chat pasten.
Ich hätte gern zu diesem Bildschirmhintergrund, den ich jetzt, das ist mein neuer Bildschirmhintergrund. Will nicht mal jemand so einen Neon-Cut als iPhone-Wallpaper bauen?
Das ist wirklich ein sehr hübsches Bildchen, die Hörerstreamvisualisierung.
Ihr merkt auch schon, wir haben eigentlich gar keine Themen heute, deswegen verlieren wir uns gleich zu Beginn.
Wir haben schon ein paar Themen, aber es sind alles so Themen, wo wir dann Angst haben, dass wir uns nicht lange unterhalten können und dann ist die Sendung auf einmal so zu Ende, ohne dass wir uns überhaupt so richtig hätten steigern können.
Ja, das hat Potenzial.
Das hat definitiv Potenzial und ich finde, es sollte auch mehr darüber nachgedacht werden, alles auf Deutsch umzubenennen. Ja, oder sich zumindest Mühe zu geben, irgendwie einen Namen zu finden, der so international ist, dass man da jetzt keinerlei Leid mit erzeugt. Neuerdings geht das ja hier auch in Berlin. Hier, du bist auch immer so Start-up fest. Vielleicht kannst du das mal kurz erklären.
Ich bin Start-up fest?
Du gabst auch wieder so eine neue Glaubensrichtung namens Armen.
Ach, Armen, ja. Armen.
Armen. Du hast bestimmt schon ein Account.
Ja, hab ich. Ein was? Ach so, ein Benutzerkonto meinst du vielleicht.
Du hast bestimmt schon ein Benutzerkonto bei Armen eingesetzt.
Hast du hier früh eine Beta-Einladung bekommen? Cosma hat die Nummer 7, die Identifikationsnummer 7 bei dem Dienst zugeteilt bekommen.
Das heißt, arbeiten genau sechs Programmierer daran oder was?
Vermutlich.
Und worum geht's bei diesem wahnsinnig tollen Unternehmen?
Das ist ein soziales Mediennetzwerk. Für starke Meinungen, über starke Meinungen, und zwar drückt man seine Meinung. Ich nutze das ja quasi gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Aber es gibt wohl viele Leute, die das massenhaft nutzen.
Weil du keine starke Meinung hast?
Oder weil du keine Beta-Einladung hast. Man kann jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, ich habe eine starke Meinung über eine Person, über einen Place oder einen Sing. Jetzt sage ich mal Sing. Und dann sage ich mal Ding. Jetzt mache ich mal Mobile Max. Mobile Max.
Das ist aber der eigene.
Ist the best. Und dann sage ich hier Podcast, Beast, 666. Und dann kann man hier sagen, Ever oder was auch immer. Dann ist das jetzt so meine starke Meinung, die ich habe, diese Aussage. Und dann tippe ich hier auf Amen. Also man muss da halt seine starke Meinung immer so Amen, Amen, Amen, Amen. Und jetzt steht hier meine Meinung, dass Mobile Max der beste Podcast Ever ist. Jetzt können andere Leute entweder sagen, ja, das arme ich auch. Da mache ich auch einen Amen drauf. Oder eben sie sagen, nein, ist überhaupt nicht wahr. In Wirklichkeit ist Bits und So der beste Podcast der Welt oder was auch immer.
Großartig.
Und ich finde... Ich habe ihn auch nicht gesehen, bis meine Freundin sich einen halben Abend voll begackert hat, weil sie die ganze Zeit auf Amen rumgeklickt hat mit irgendwelchen anderen Leuten und sich auf Amen und sie sich gegenseitig irgendwie die Meinung um die Ohren gehauen haben und dann haben bestätigen lassen. Da sind auch echt witzige Sachen dabei. Ich sehe jetzt nicht, dass es so das Megapotenzial hat, wie, sagen wir mal, Twitter oder sowas, aber für die Beschränktheit, die es hat, hat es schon mir den einen oder anderen sehr netten Moment bereitet.
Ja, aber auf Twitter haben doch alle eine starke Meinung.
Nee, meine Theorie ist ja, wenn du, wenn man die Leute da...
Namen zu sagen.
Genau, aber wenn man die Leute dazu bringen kann, das zu nutzen. Ich habe keine Idee, wieso das so ist.
Also ich verstehe, ich habe ehrlich gesagt noch überhaupt nicht verstanden, was eigentlich Sinn und Zweck der ganzen Sache ist, außer dass man seine Meinung kundgibt.
Aber reicht das nicht?
War das nicht bei Twitter auch am Anfang so?
Also bei Podcasts schon ist, ich glaube, 98 Prozent an der Internet.
Ja, nein, aber ich meine, ja, aber ich meine, wenn das sowieso jeder Dienst macht, warum muss man dann noch einen Dienst machen, der das betont, dass das genau darum geht? Ich meine, gibt es irgendeine... Was ist, wenn Leute anderer Meinung sind? Kann man dann...
Du kannst die Meinung disputen. Du kannst sagen, nein, das ist nicht meine Meinung, in Wirklichkeit ist das so und so. Du kannst auch Statist...
Anzweifeln.
Anzweifeln, genau.
Anfechten vielleicht sogar.
Anfechten.
Ja, und dann kannst du, man kann auch Statistiken sehen, wie viele Leute haben das gesehen, wie viele Leute haben das gesehen. Es gibt Punkte dafür, wenn Leute sagen, der gleichen Meinung sind wie du. Und ja, das ist, und ich glaube, es kann ganz hervorragend funktionieren. Also ich weiß nicht, ob sich das Usermodell da ist, aber die Datenbank, die die aufbauen, die könnte der totale Hammer sein, glaube ich. Also ich glaube Geschäftsmodell haben die. Naja, wenn du in Echtzeit die Leute ihrer Meinung zu irgendeinem Thema rauspumpen, ich glaube, das sind Statistiken, die kannst du an Firmen verkloppen. FDP ist the best party ever, dann kannst du hier in das Beste werden, glaubt er das heute Abend? Aber ich bin auch nicht überzeugt. Ist ganz lustig.
Ja, also irgendwie, also wahrscheinlich sehe ich das Licht da jetzt noch nicht so richtig, was jetzt so der Punkt ist, aber mein Anreiz, da aufzuschlagen, um mir vielleicht eine Beta-Einladung einzufangen, ist begrenzt. Geht's dir auch so Hucke?
Ja, ja, also ich bin auch schon fast bei dieser Besprechung eingeschlafen, tatsächlich.
Also sagen wir Amen dazu? Was ist eigentlich passiert? Es ist eigentlich gar nichts passiert. Aber wollen wir mal mit den ekligen Sachen anfangen?
John Grober wird jetzt Microsoft-Fanboy.
Ich muss das ja mal bringen, weil mir ja auch immer irgendwie so gnadenloses Fanboy-Tum.
Ach, jetzt nutzt du auch die Gelegenheit mal Windows, äh, Fenster 8 ganz okay zu finden.
Nee, nee, es geht so.
Achso.
Ja, ja. Dann kommen wir jetzt noch zu... Aber euch ist aufgefallen, dass wieder dieses widerliche Ereignis war. Letzten Samstag machte ein neuer Apfelladen auf.
In Hamburg.
In Hamburg. Und es war wieder dieses... Und es war schon wieder dieses Gehabe, dieses Getue, war schon wieder am Start.
Welches Gehabe, Getue?
Dieses Geschrei, dieses Kreische und dieses ganze Geklatsche. Ach, warst du da?
Nein, ich hab nur... Nein, das gab's im Internet.
Ich kann dir hier gerne mal die URL mal kurz nochmal vor die Nase werfen. Aber ich... Soll ich einen Ton anmachen?
Ich fand's auch sehr anstrengend. Ich hab's nach wenigen Sekunden... Ohne Ton?
Aber vielleicht doch auch mit Ton? Ich weiß nicht.
Also wegen mir muss nicht. Ich hab's schon gesehen.
Leute in der Schlange, Leute in der Schlange, Leute in der Schlange.
Also da sind so Leute.
Leute in der Schlange.
Ich spule mal vor hier.
Was ist das denn für ein Übergang?
So, jetzt machen sie halt diesen Laden auf. Und jetzt laufen wir wirklich diese albernen Leute da in diesen albernen furchtbaren T-Shirts. Und was mich... Also ich meine Apple hin, Apple her, ja? Aber diese T-Shirt-Farbe, die geht schon mal gar nicht. Alle diese T-Shirt-Farben, die sind einfach mal nicht gut. Das ist einfach kein korrektes Blau, ja? Ich meine, das ist schon irgendwie Blau, aber es sieht einfach überhaupt nicht classy aus, kein Stück.
Das ist Blue Screen of Death-Blau, oder?
Nee, es ist einfach so ein vollkommen übersaturiertes, triefendes Leuchte-Blau. Ja, und kein gediegenes Understatement-Blau. Ich meine, okay, das mag ja damit zu tun haben, dass ja diese T-Shirts gerade in der Organisation eines Apple Stores auch enorme Signalwirkung haben sollen. Dass du ja genau weißt, wohin. Aber ich denke, das könnte man auch mit einer anderen Tönung ganz gut erreichen. Das ist mir ein bisschen mit dem Funken zu amerikanisch. Aber damit könnte ich noch leben. Aber ich meine, was treibt diese Leute? Ich meine, was müssen die in ihrer Ausbildung bereits vor der Eröffnung dieses Ladens durchmachen, dass sie sich zu so einer eher niedrigenden Show da...
Na die haben am Alex so einen kostenlosen Stresstest gemacht.
Aber guck doch mal, wie voll das da ist.
Naja klar, und das verstehe ich auch nicht.
Ich verstehe mich am allerwenigsten.
Auf beiden Seiten finde ich mich einfach mal überhaupt nicht wieder.
Ach also ich war ja schon mal auf dieser Seite, die wir jetzt gerade sehen, auf der Kundenseite.
Ja. Aber ich meine, was, bejubeln Sie bitte, was? Es gibt da nichts zu jubeln. Der Laden hat auf, er sieht genauso aus wie alle anderen Läden, er hat exakt dieselben Produkte wie alle anderen Apple Stores auch. What's?
Ich nehme die Kamera mit, wenn Tim dann mal beim Apple Store in Berlin ist.
Ja glaubt man nicht, dass ich da auflaufen werde und mir dieses Klatschen, dieses Gejohlen und dieses Türmchen gespiele da und wir laufen da alle durch und vor allem weiter hinten. Dann fangen ja dann auch noch die Kunden an. Weißt du, die laufen da jetzt rein und dann stehen dann diese blauen Affen links und rechts bei dir und dann muss das auch noch abgeklatscht werden. Wo sind wir denn hier? Auf einem Basketballspiel oder was?
Offensichtlich.
Hallo beim Apple kaufen!
Ich finde das einfach furchtbar und stillos. Ich finde das furchtbar. Also da kann ich Leute wirklich verstehen, wenn sie diesem ganzen Apple-Kult so eine bekloppte Religions-Einstellung unterstellen. Also an der Stelle kann ich das echt gut nachvollziehen. Ja, was, was? Hier, guck.
Furchtbar.
Jetzt müssen die da so reinrennen und...
Die armen Menschen.
Ja, ich meine denk doch einfach mal über die Virenverbreitung nach.
Ja, also was da...
Jetzt gerade wo es kälter wird.
Ungewaschene, ja, das auch noch im Herbst, ja. Also das ist doch einfach mal überhaupt nicht...
Apple-Joser sind nicht ungewaschen.
Ja, und dann dieses Apple-Moin-Moin, was die da noch die ganze Zeit rufen. Also wirklich wie auf so einem schlechten...
Da würde sich der Steve im Grabe umdrehen.
Ja, wenn der das wüsste, ja.
Das ist einfach mal...
Westkurve ist das. Das ist einfach ein proletarisches Geschrei und Bejubelung von nichts. Was passiert da? Die kriegen ja noch nicht mal was geschenkt oder so.
Doch, doch.
Ja, ein hässliches T-Shirt. Ich hab auch ein schwarzes T-Shirt. Es gab schwarze T-Shirts?
Ich hab damals ein schwarzes T-Shirt bekommen. Ja, die sind dann in so einer Box drin, in so einer weißen Box. Da war ein schwarzes T-Shirt drin, was ich nie angeboten hab.
Ich war immer irgendwie auf diesem iOS-Developer-Day und da haben sie auch wirklich ein T-Shirt rausgegeben. So ein beklopptes Ich-war-dabei-T-Shirt. Und das hatte einfach noch ein unerträglicheres Blau.
Warum läuft da eigentlich Windows 7 auf deinem iMac?
Ich mach das mal aus.
Ich will gar keinen Apple Store in Berlin haben mehr.
Ich mach jetzt echt keinen Witz, aber ich hab mir dieses Video angeguckt. Mir ist wirklich schlecht geworden. Und ich hab mir wirklich gedacht so, was bitte ist die Marke, auf die ich jetzt ausweichen kann? Ja, also das hat mich völlig, das entleibt mich förmlich. Also da will ich keinen Apple mehr kaufen. Da vergeht mir der Spaß an der Marke total. Also richtig vollständig und nachhaltig. Das macht mich kaputt. Ich will das nicht. Ich finde es okay, dass sie so Läden haben, mit Service und so und dann bauen sie die so schick. Dann sollen die sich auch entsprechend benehmen.
Wie sollen sie sich da benehmen?
Mit Stil und nicht da irgendwie mit stinkenden Achseln herumstehen und irgendwie einen die ganze Zeit befingern. Was ist denn das für ein Benehmen? Die sollen sich da höflich benehmen. Sollen sie mal nach England fahren und sich mal irgendwie benimmend beibringen lassen.
Ich glaube im Englischen Apple Store machen die das genauso.
Die sollen sich dezent hinstellen und sagen, schön, dass du da bist. Toll! Eigentlich dieses...
Aber das machen sie ja auch fairerweise nur am ersten Tag, ne? Also...
Gott sei Dank. Sonst hätte ich schon...
Stell dir das mal...
Nee, dann würde ich da sofort mit einer Stinkbombe auflaufen.
Buttersäure.
Oder das wär's vielleicht eigentlich für so eine Applestore-Eröffnung. Einfach so mit einer Pumpgun rein.
Supersoker.
Also mit so einer Waterpumpgun rein. Nee, nee, nee. Also kein Aufruf zu Straftaten. Nee, aber so, weißt du...
Nur Buttersäure.
Kein Aufruf zu Straftaten. Das stimmt ja nur.
Das war ja mal mein Plan über diese Scientology-Ständen. Da haben wir so mit dem Fahrrad vorbei und mal mit dem Supersoaker so ein bisschen Buttersäure auf ihre Werke, weil die wollen sie dann auch nicht mehr einpacken, glaube ich. Aber ich hab mich noch nicht getraut, wenn mir mal langweilig ist.
Ja, mit Buttersäure könnte man wahrscheinlich wirklich so ein paar Justierungen vornehmen für eine Gesellschaft, die mal längst überfällig sind. Ich bin jetzt schon wieder in der falschen Sendung.
Wo bin ich wieder gelandet?
Also, Apple, Apple, moin moin.
Ich sag nur Apple, Apple, oh wei, oh wei. Es geht bergab.
Das ist wirklich, also das hab ich noch nie begriffen. Was sagt denn der Chat dazu?
Findet ihr das gut?
Nee, sind auch sehr verständnisvoll, glaube ich.
Lasst die Leute noch ihren Spaß haben. Wenn sie hin wollen, wollen sie hin. Irgendetwas müssen sie noch bieten.
Was, wenn du bei so einem Apple Store-Laden arbeiten würdest? Stell dir mal vor, Berlin schreibt jetzt aus. Du denkst, der scheiß Programmierung bringt eh nichts.
Werde ich Verkäufer dem Apple Store.
Genau, dann kommst du da hin, bist zwei Monate vorher da, dann wirst du einmal nach Cupertino geflogen und darfst dann auch mal die Steine anfassen, wo es die lange gelaufen ist.
Und wenn ich dafür nach Cupertino geflogen werde, dann mach ich da auch mal so einen Teil Laub am Alpen.
Ich hab gehört, dass die durchaus auch in den USA Ausbildung erfahren, wenn nicht alle, dann zumindest in Teilen. Ich glaub nur in Teilen. Ja, aber die auf jeden Fall.
Das ist auch wie bei Scientology, so mit den Levels, die man...
Ja, wie heißt das noch gleich? Wie heißt noch gleich dieses Scientology-Level? O-tan?
Autan? Sakrotan.
Den dritten Autan, genau. Was wollte ich sagen? So, pass auf. Und dann kommt dieser Eröffnungstag. Und dann sagen sie dir so, bitte, jetzt mach mir die Türen auf und du benimmst dich jetzt für eine halbe Stunde wie ein Idiot. Benimmst du dich dann wie ein Idiot?
Muss ich darauf jetzt antworten?
Ja, aber ist ja gut, vielleicht wirft dich das ja...
Ich glaube, die Leute, die da arbeiten, die wissen das schon vorher. Das trifft die da nicht unerwartet.
Das ist im Internet, das kann auf Ewigkeiten abgerufen werden. Alle ihre Freunde sehen, wie sie sich da...
Die rennen da so ein bisschen rum und lassen sich mal ein bisschen feiern, ist ja okay.
Wegen was?
Weil sie da einen Laden aufmachen, weil sie sich alle freuen und weißt ja toll, was.
Ich glaube einfach keinem, dass er sich da so freut.
Ich war ja in Dresden und ich hab den auch gefragt, was ist denn das, was haben sie euch denn gegeben, dass ihr hier so... Der hat sich wirklich so gefreut. Der war wirklich knallrot, der war richtig, der war richtig, hast richtig mitgekriegt, wie das Adrenalin pumpt und so. Der war richtig, der hat sich wirklich gefreut. Vielleicht haben sie ihnen auch Drogen gegeben, ich hab keine Ahnung. Sie hat überhaupt keine Drogen gekriegt. Das machte ein bisschen Eindruck, aber ich hatte das Gefühl, als ob sie das wirklich ihnen Spaß machen würde, als ob sie dazu nicht gezogen worden wären.
So die Haare, Krishna Leute und so.
Ja, das ist so die ganz normale Hirnwischerheit.
Das ganz normale Reality-Distortion-Field. Das Realitätsverzerrungsfeld.
Oh Gott, wie viele Anglizismen haben wir jetzt versehentlich eingebaut?
Ja, ich hoffe nicht so viele, sonst wären wir ja dann gerügt. Vor allem kommt dann die Gesellschaft für deutsche Sprache.
Und klopft uns auf die Tome.
Also ich bin dagegen.
Ich dachte du wolltest über das andere, ich dachte du wolltest über den finalen Schnitt Angestellte Arbeitstätigkeit berichten.
Finaler Schnitt...
Oh Gott, also Eigennamen fallen raus. Jetzt hast du mich aber echt verwirrt. Ich kann da nicht viel zu sagen, ich hab mir das Ding vor zwei Stunden gekauft. Achso, vor zwei Stunden?
Dafür hast du aber ganz gut geflucht.
20... naja klar, weil es ging ja nicht. Tetan heißt das, genau. OT, operierender Tetan.
Ach der Scheiße.
Ich hatte OT, also OT gibt es als Abkürzung.
Fragen wir uns natürlich gleich, woher Urim das so weiß.
Na steht in der Fiki Fiki Fiki Fiki steht das. Habe ich in der Fiki Pedo-Bär nachgefragt. Falsche Sendung. Ja wollen wir dann einfach gleich über Windows reden, wenn es vorbei ist mit den Apple Stores, dann schauen wir doch mal, was da für Alternativen im Raum stehen. Also es war eine Developer-Konferenz, das kam für mich sehr überraschend.
Die war höchstens seit 5 Monaten angekündigt.
Ist nicht so, dass mir jemand Bescheid gesagt hätte oder so. Stand auch in keinem Kalender.
Also hier am Microsoft Developer-Konferenz, nicht Apple.
Genau.
Und jetzt ist alles ganz metrosexuell.
Ja, genau.
Also was haben sie getan? Sie haben ein Preview, wie heißt das bei Microsoft so? Vorschau auf Windows 8.
Fenster 8, genau.
Winzig schweiß.
Und naja, also wenn ich es so richtig verstanden habe, gehen sie da wirklich einen merkwürdigen Weg. Also sie wollen irgendwie immer noch bei dieser Single OS Strategie bleiben. Und das bedeutet ja auch, dass sie dieses Windows Phone 7 Ding irgendwie vermutlich...
Damit reinholen wollen?
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau. Also klar ist ja, dass dieses neue Metro-UI, was sie da jetzt vor... Ist das überhaupt das erste Mal so vorgestellt worden? Das hat sich vorher schon abgezeichnet, ne?
Das ist ja auf den Windows Phone-Geräten auch schon Metro.
Das hieß da auch schon immer Metro?
Das ist quasi eine Weiterentwicklung jetzt.
Aber irgendwas war... Also da weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau, weil ich hab mir dieses Zeug nicht bis zum Ende angucken können, ich hatte zu wenig Zeit. Aber es gab ja da einige Vorträge, die jetzt auch als Video veröffentlicht wurden. Kannst du mir das mal erklären. Und da war irgendwas von die Rede, dass es irgendwie ein... Dass sie jetzt nicht mehr dort nett machen?
Naja, also ich hab keinen technischen Vortrag gesehen. Ich hab tatsächlich diesen Vortrag, der so viel gelobt worden ist, über diese Metro-UI gesehen. Also wo quasi die Entwickler darauf eingeschworen sind auf diese neue Oberfläche und was sie damit machen sollen. Und wie toll das alles ist irgendwie schön und wie leicht und was auch immer. Da war technisch keine Sekunde lang die Rede von. Ich weiß, dass sie damals irgendwann gesagt haben, dass man diese ganzen Dinger jetzt in JavaScript schreiben soll gefälligst. Und nicht in Silverlight oder Dottnet oder sowas.
Und auch nicht in C-Lattenzorn.
Und auch nicht in C-Scharf. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch der Fall ist oder ob sie dann mittlerweile sich mal ein bisschen weiter aus ein bisschen entspannt haben sozusagen und dann ein bisschen mehr zulassen.
Also auf der Seite zu Windows 8 in der Wikipedia finden sich auf Anny jedenfalls nicht zu Dottnet oder zu JavaScript. Das wäre ja wohl hier eine Erwähnung wert gewesen.
Also jetzt haben sie irgendwie über Jahre diese ganze Dottnet.
Das will ich auch nicht so richtig verstehen, ehrlich gesagt.
Also hier der Mensch mit einem unversprechlichen Nick meint, Dottnet bleibt, man kann Metro in allem schreiben.
Also es ist doch noch da.
Ich frage mich auch, warum sie jetzt überhaupt da noch Development in JavaScript, also warum sie das noch mal separat, also warum sie das überhaupt machen? Also wo ist die Notwendigkeit dazu, das zu tun? Warum brauchen sie noch mal ein neues?
Na ja, um die ganzen hippen Grafiker, die eigentlich gar nicht programmieren können, auch an Boards holen, die aber schicke Ups machen, die aber nichts können.
Genau.
So für yet another Twitter-Frontend oder sowas. Yet another... noch ein weiteres.
Noch ein weiteres, genau.
Die Begeisterung strudelt uns aus einem Punkt. Ich finde das ja durchaus interessant, dass sie überhaupt in der Lage sind, mal darüber nachzudenken, mal ihr User-Interface komplett zu ändern, auch wenn das ja eigentlich noch nicht neu war. Und sie es ja auf diesem Windows-Phone auch schon gebracht haben mit diesen Kacheln.
Das macht schon eine Menge her, finde ich.
Ich habe das noch nie so richtig benutzt. Von daher weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt einem, einer täglichen Benutzung wirklich so entgegenkommt. Aber das ist zumindest mal ein anderes Modell. Sie sind zumindest die einzigen, die jetzt nicht direkt Apple eins zu eins kopieren.
Wir haben eigentlich einen kompletten Gegenentwurf geliefert. Während Apple ja so 3D und Eyecandy und alles polished und Mitte verläuft und Schatten und Spiegelung und weiß-er-taufe-was, ist das einfach grüne Fläche auf blaue Fläche. Und dafür viel Typografie.
Aber um ehrlich zu sein, ich habe meine Zweifel, dass sie mit dieser Strategie erfolgreich sein werden. Weil ich frage mich ernsthaft, wer ist da jetzt für die Zielgruppe? Also das Business ist ja...
Wollen wir erstmal erzählen, was es ist? Also ich habe ja dieses Video gesehen und das war schon, was ich nämlich daran ganz spannend fand, dass sie an einigen Stellen extrem weiter gedacht haben als Apple. Also sie haben auch auf Apple ein bisschen eingedroschen. Der Vortrag, das war so dieser Design Vortrag, der über Metro. Den kann man sich auch echt gut geben. Der Typ, der den vorgestellt hat, der hat das ziemlich witzig gemacht. Das war unterhaltsam, macht Spaß, das zu gucken. Und man kriegt halt eine ganz spannende Technologie vorgeführt. Und die haben halt diese Tiles da auf ihrem Startscreen, also eigentlich im Wesentlichen nennt man sowas früher, glaube ich, Rechtecke. Und die haben... Und das sind jetzt quasi, das sind so ein bisschen so wie klassische Icons, außer dass sie eben so ein Notification-System eingebaut haben. Und ein Notification-System, was relativ ähnlich ist dem vom iOS, außer dass es eben so unauffällig abgeht. Also es soll so sein, man soll ohne das Programm zu starten, zu müssen, soll man schon die wesentlichen Informationen haben. Also als Beispiel haben sie die Wetter-App genannt, die Wetter-Applikation. Und man sieht schon, wie das Wetter wird, auch ohne dass man die App startet. Und man klickt da einfach dadurch, dass sich das selber aktualisiert. Und sie haben halt so was, was die Gesten angeht, haben sie doch an einigen Punkten ganz ordentlich weitergedacht. Also sie haben sich zum Beispiel über diesen Moduswechsel, dem hat er geradezu sich drüber lustig gemacht sozusagen, dass man mit einem Long-Tap irgendwas hält und dann wechselt man den Modus, das hat man auf dem Springboard, man hält den Icon ein bisschen länger und dann fangen die alle an, rum zu jiggeln. Und dann kann man plötzlich andere Sachen machen, die man vorher nicht so machen kann. Das ist bei denen so gemacht. Also wenn man, man kann die so mit so einer Geste, mit so einer Schnapp, mit so einer Finger-Geste nach unten, kann man die so, da sieht man, wie er den Finger so bewegt, dieses, kann man die so nach unten ziehen und dann werden die so markiert so ein bisschen. Wenn man sie weiter nach unten zieht, dann fängt man sie an zu bewegen. Und dann kann man mit der anderen Hand, kann man unten drunter die Wallpaper sozusagen hin und her bewegen. Also wenn man es auf eine andere Page verschieben will, dann hat man nicht so dieses Problem wie unter IOS, dass man es an den Bildschirm heranschieben muss und darauf hofft, dass es irgendwann weitergeht, sondern man kann einfach unten drunter mit der anderen Hand die Sachen hin und her schieben. Und also da haben sie sich schon, da haben sie echt eine Menge Hirnschmales reingesteckt, das vernünftig zu machen. Und Natifications gehen sind komplett anderen Weg. Also da sind sie halt, also sie haben, es gibt kein Notification, so wie jetzt auch bei iOS 5 oder bei Android. Die haben es genannt, Data Dump. Also wo du so all, wo du plötzlich so dieses ganze, alle Mails und so, wo du das alles hast. Nein, das wollen wir nicht. Wir wollen das nur, es gibt Notifications und die zeigst du an und die sind danach weg. Das ist erklärtes Konzept, dass du die nicht irgendwo aufbewahrst. Und alle anderen Informationen, die nicht direkt dein, also da soll wirklich nur das Allerwichtigste, also nur, wenn du einen Anruf bekommst oder wenn du jetzt keine Ahnung, so wirklich SMS oder so was. Und diese ganzen anderen Sachen, wo man sowohl bei Android als auch bei iOS eine Notification für kriegt, das soll übers Icon laufen. Also ändere lieber das Icon oder das Teil von deinem, ähm, Hessen Teil auf Deutsch, ändere die Kachel deiner Applikation und zeig keine Notification an. Und ähm, ja, macht einen intelligent weitergedachten Eindruck. Und ist jetzt so das erste, wo ich so denke, das kann Apple nicht mal innerhalb kürzester Zeit nachbauen, im Zweifelsfall, wenn sie in die Richtung wollen. Kann man sich gut geben, den Vortrag.
Ja, aber es ist jetzt nichts im eigentlichen Sinne drin, was jetzt bei iOS gar nicht da ist, es ist nur anders.
Was heißt was gar nicht da? Also sowas wie diese Teil... Sie haben jetzt die Welt nicht neu erfunden. Aber sie haben einen komplett anderen Ansatz an User Interfaces gebaut. Und sie haben halt diesen Start-Screen, der ist halt eine kleine Informationsbörse. Und das ist schon... Also zum Beispiel geht es auch darum, dass, wenn du eben, was weiß ich, was deine Facebook-App schreibst, dann soll die auch gerne Fotos anzeigen von deinen Freunden, damit du die auch immer auf deinem Start-Screen hast. Also es geht sehr stark darum, dass man sich eigenster, also teils da nach vorne holt. Nicht nur, weil man die App tatsächlich braucht, sondern damit es auch schön ist. Also sie haben so ein sehr eigenes User Interface da, sich ausgedacht, was auch so auf Schönheit bedacht ist, sozusagen. Und das ist ja bisher nicht unbedingt Microsofts Stärke gewesen.
Ne, das kann man nicht sagen. Ich finde das auch sehr interessant, wir haben das ja auch schon tausendmal beklagt, dass uns eigentlich immer noch so dieses, so ein richtiges Dashboard mal fehlt. Und das, also schon damals, als ich noch mein Nokia-Telefon hatte, damals. Eine Sache könnte sich echt immer noch besser als mein iPhone. Das könnte mir einfach mal den fucking nächsten Termin, den ich habe, anzeigen.
Das ist hier definitiv. Das kann Windows Phone jetzt schon, aber...
Ja, das ist ja schon immer drin gewesen. Und da habe ich auch ehrlich gesagt, da kann ich so richtig gar nicht nachvollziehen, warum sie das jetzt auch mit iOS 5 immer noch nicht gebracht haben. Weil das ist einfach mal so... naheliegend. Oder versteht da irgendwas falsch? Eigentlich, was könnte sie... Ich meine, was könnte sie wirklich ernsthaft davon abhalten, außer dass sie noch wirklich total drüber nachdenken, wie das aussehen soll? Weil es gab ja auch so Programme, die so ähnliche Dinge probiert haben und die haben sie dann irgendwie wegen Duplicate Functionality abgewählt. Nur, dass es diese Duplicate Functionality so eigentlich gar nicht gab. Kann ich gerade den Namen nicht nennen, aber es gab so ein, zwei Ups, die versucht haben, in diese Richtung zu gehen.
Na, also was hier definitiv ein bisschen problematisch dran ist, an diesem Ansatz ist, die Alkans der Apps ändern sich halt ziemlich radikal. Und wenn du denen nicht gerade die Position gemerkt hast, hast du glaube ich echt ein Problem, das wieder zu finden. Also ihm ist es in seiner Demo so gegangen, dass er plötzlich von einer App, dass er kurz zögern musste, weil er das Icon nicht mehr wieder gefunden hat. Und da sind natürlich die iOS-Icons extrem geil, weil die sind farblich und so extrem darauf optimiert, dass man es so schnell wieder findet. Und wenn du alle zehn Sekunden so ein App-Icon änderst, dann findest du es halt nicht mehr. Also es ist schon, du gehst da mit Kompromisse bei der Einfachheit ein, dadurch, dass du mehr Informationen hast. Und ich glaube, das ist einfach eine Philosophie. Also eine Richtung, in die Apple im Augenblick nicht gehen will. Also die sind da im Augenblick noch bei ihren Notifications, die oben angezeigt werden, und damit hat sich der Salat. Also diese kleinen Bobbles, diese Badges.
Ja, das denke ich auch, dass das damit eine Menge zu tun haben kann, dass man dann sich einfach... Also es ist halt auch wieder, dieses Customization steht im Vorder... also die Anpassbarkeit steht im Vordergrund.
Hier bei Windows?
Mhm, auch schon immer so.
Ich meine, es gab ja... das ist ja auch... ich sehe hier auch so alte Dinge wiederkommen, so Active Desktop und so.
So ein bisschen schon.
Die haben ja auch schon ganz früh versucht, mit HTML irgendwie ihre Oberfläche zu zaubern. Also diese Idee ist gar nicht neu bei Microsoft.
Also es ist wesentlich benutzerfreundlicher, das ist es auf jeden Fall. Es ist krass, was...
Wesentlich benutzerfreundlicher als was.
Also als ein Active Desktop. Also bei Active Desktop, das war ja wirklich grau und schlechthin. Du nimmst halt diese Icons oder diese Teils oder wie auch immer sie heißen und schiebst sie an die richtige Stelle und kannst sie nach vorne holen. Du kannst, was ich ziemlich geil finde, aus jeder App heraus kannst du beliebig viele Teils anlegen. Also du kannst... Kacheln. Du kannst also aus deiner Facebook-App heraus, das war jetzt quasi, war nicht Facebook, war es Social irgendwas, aber im Endeffekt war es Facebook. Kannst du zum Beispiel für einzelne Freunde kannst du sagen, hier, ich möchte direkt auf mein Startbildschirm, möchte ich gerne eine Kachel haben, nur für diesen Freund. Oder ich möchte gerne aus meiner Wetter-App heraus möchte ich ein zweites Alken haben oder eine zweite Kachel auf dem Startbildschirm, nur für diese Stadt. Ich habe zwei Städte, in denen ich ständig bin, also. Hier die Stadt, da die Stadt. Und das macht, das ist cool. Das macht eine Menge her, finde ich. Was sie noch haben, das ist so dieses, wie heißt es, Contracts. Das ist was, was iOS auch ziemlich abgeht. Verträge. Also ein Contract in diesem Sinne ist eigentlich ein Service. Also jede App soll Services entweder Service zur Verfügung stellen oder Services empfangen können. Also zum Beispiel ein Service kann sein, ich kann ein Bild zur Verfügung stellen. Ich bin eine Foto-App und ich kann Bilder zur Verfügung stellen und eine andere App sagt, hallo, ich bin eine Foto-Empfangs-App und kann Bilder bei Twitter hochladen.
Im Prinzip ist es so wie die Intents bei Android.
Ich kenne die Intents bei Android nicht so genau, aber kann durchaus, erinnerte mich auch so ein bisschen an die Richtung. Und das ist hier einfach wiederum ganz gut ins Betriebssystem eingebaut. Also das ist halt, du kannst, so über so eine Geste, also die haben links und rechts, die linken und rechten Ränder sind von Microsoft fest dominiert. Links ist irgendwie zum App wechseln und rechts gibt es da diese, wie heißen die? Charms? Was soll man das heißen sollen? Was heißt denn Charms? Können wir mal Charms übersetzen?
Charm heißt Charm.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Nee, also irgendwas anderes muss das bedeuten. Egal, und da konnte man auf jeden Fall sagen, ich möchte jetzt gerne mit der Information, die ich habe, irgendwas anstellen.
Amulett.
Und es ging halt darum, dass du...
Power or quality of giving delight or arousing admiration.
Nein, auch Liebreiz, Zaubertalisman.
Okay, also wenn man eine Geste mit dem Finger von rechts macht, dann hat man den windlos Liebreiz.
Ist geil, ne? Liebreiz, Balmer.
Ich weiß jetzt, wie diese Nounke heißt. Glücksbringer, keine Ahnung, was das ist. Auf jeden Fall ist das, kann man da eben, es macht einen sehr gediegenen Eindruck, wie er da eben so irgendwie das Bild genommen hat und es dann quasi rübergeschoben hat in den Tweet und den dann sofort abgesendet hat. Und das macht da schon ein bisschen was her.
Also was ich ja ein bisschen merkwürdig finde, ist dieses, also ich sag, es gibt da so verschiedene Sachen, die ich da merkwürdig dran finde. Also grundsätzlich erstmal volle Credits dafür, dass sie überhaupt mal in der Lage sind, irgendwas anderes rauszubringen, als das, was sie jetzt schon seit 20 Jahren machen.
Ganz kurz nochmal, was das Krasse daran ist, dass natürlich so die ganzen, die Notifications, die klingen eins zu eins, so wie von Apple geklaut, sie suspenden jede App, die im Hintergrund läuft, genauso wie Apple es macht. Sie haben knallharte Vorgaben, diese Teils auf dem Homescreen, das ist nicht so, dass du da so pixelgenau steuern kannst. Du hast da Templates, da kannst du deinen Text hinpacken, oder da kannst du deinen Text hinpacken. Du kannst auch nicht die Animationen selber bestimmen, sondern wird vom Betriebssystem gesteuert, sodass die Animationen immer aufeinander abgestimmt sind bei den einzelnen Teils.
Also ich glaube, das müssen sie ja wahrscheinlich auch schon allein deshalb machen, damit sie den ganzen Stromverbrauch irgendwie nicht kriegen.
Natürlich, aber sie klauen da gnadenlos bei Apple. Sie nutzen jetzt, also Apple hat da einmal es durch den Shitstorm in Anführungsstrichen gelaufen, also kann ja kein echtes Multitasking und Microsoft wird den Teil genau so machen. Da wird es einen Market für geben oder Store, ich weiß nicht, wie das bei denen heißt, und da werden die Apps drin sein und du wirst nichts anderes bekommen und das wird ziemlich sicher genau das gleiche Ökosystem werden, wie Apple das hat. Also die Oberfläche sieht komplett anders aus, unten drunter ist es weitestgehend, würde ich sagen, Apple-Kopie.
Was sollen sie auch schon anders machen, aber auf der anderen Seite haben sie auch, ein paar Sachen sind einfach überhaupt gar keine Kopie. ZB sie gehen von ganz anderen Annahmen aus. Also ich sehe z.B. nur Landscape. Während bei Apple eigentlich, ich meine, der Default, wie du dein iPad benutzt, ist Portrait-Modus.
Ah ja, ich benutze beides ziemlich, also ich glaube, ich benutze mehr Landscape.
Ja, du benutzt beides, du benutzt mal das und du benutzt mal das, ja. Aber wenn du so, auch schon das IOS ist ja, also das iPhone, der I-Telefon ist von vornherein auf Portrait geeicht. Das ist ja wirklich so, du hast z.B. den Homescreen, den Heimatbildschirm, hast du nur in Portrait. Also den gibt's gar nicht in Landschaft. Kannst du da nicht durch die Landschaft rollen und... Rollen? Rollen.
Wischen. Durch die Landschaft wischen. Berühren.
So, gibt's gar nicht.
Beim iPad gibt's das schon, aber trotzdem ist so das Ding zu verwenden wie ein Buch und auch viele Anwendungen, also alle Anwendungen können auch Portrait und hier ist irgendwie alles voll auf Landschaftsmodus ausgelegt. Auch so mit diesen Seiten und so. Also ich seh auch die ganze Zeit nur Landscape.
Der Homebutton ist ja auch sowieso.
Und die haben auch die Kamera woanders.
Ich weiß gar nicht, haben die einen richtigen Homebutton? Also die hatten diese Charms da halt?
Es gibt im Landscape-Modus sozusagen im Landschaftsmodus unten in der Mitte auch ein Windows-Homebutton.
Ich glaube, der hat aber nicht immer benutzt.
Ja, aber auch die Kameras sind bei diesen ganzen Tabletten. Es sind immer quasi oben auf der breiten Seite.
Bei dem Ding muss man jetzt ja sagen, es gibt noch gar keine Tabletten dafür.
Ja, nee, man muss noch was anderes zu dem Ding sagen. Es gibt dieses Ding noch gar nicht. Es ist angekündigt für irgendwann mal nächstes Jahr.
Vielleicht auch übernächstes.
Genau, vielleicht auch übernächstes Jahr.
Ja, ja, das ist noch ewig hin.
Wenn es nur 8 kommt, ist nächstes Jahr raus.
Frühstens.
Es ist nicht so, dass das jetzt rauskommt. Das ist halt nächstes Jahr irgendwann.
Das hat er auch mehrfach gesagt. Es sind mehrfach Geräte abgestürzt. Er hat auch zu den Entwicklern so scherzhaft gesagt, wenn ihr nach Hause kommt, ihr werdet schon wissen, warum wir das Developer Preview nennen, weil es stürzt ab ohnehin. Das scheint wirklich noch unfertig zu sein. Es geht darum, die Entwickler auf dieses User-Interface einzuschwören. Das kannst du auch nicht.
Und morgen verkaufen wir diese Geräte. Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe mal eine Zweifel, ob ihnen das gelingen wird, die Entwickler auf dieses User-Interface einzuschwören.
Das ist eine spannende Frage.
Ich meine, wer kauft das? Microsofts großer Markt ist natürlich der Enterprise-Markt. Und ich glaube, die Bereitschaft von Windows 7 auf Windows 8 zu upgraden ist irgendwo zwischen 0 und 1%. Ich habe von nichts gehört in Windows 8, was jetzt für den Enterprise-Markt irgendwie ein wertes Upgrade wäre.
Aber Windows 8 gibt es auch noch gar nicht. Ich meine, das ist ja noch weit hinten.
Ja, ich rede aber jetzt von, wenn es dann mal auf den Markt kommt. Und ich meine, das ist... Windows 7 ist gerade ihre Cash Cow. Das muss man mal ganz klar so sehen. Weil sie das erste Mal geschafft haben, nach mehreren Jahren ein OS auf den Tisch zu legen, wo alle gesagt haben, okay, jetzt machen wir mal den Schritt. Guck dir mal die Statistiken an, was so für Betriebssysteme am verbreitetsten sind. Und vor allem welche Windows-Versionen am verbreitetsten sind. Und es ist einfach so, dass Windows XP immer noch das dominante Windows ist da draußen. Muss man sich mal vorstellen. Von wann ist das nochmal?
2001.
2001. Das ist ungefähr so, als ob das meistverbreitete Mac OS X die Version 10.0 wäre.
Naja, sie haben ja zwischendurch ein paar Mal Updates gemacht für XP. Also gibt's ja auch Service Pack irgendwas.
Ja, klar. Aber es hat sich ja an dem OS selber nichts nennenswertes getan.
Sagen wir mal auf dem Niveau von 10.3.
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall haben sie verschiedene Versionen versucht danach durchzubringen auf dem Markt. Und es ist ihnen halt erst mit Windows 7 gelungen. Windows 7 war dann eben die richtige Mischung aus. Es ist jetzt dann doch schon lang genug her und wir haben so viele moderne Hardware und wir wollen jetzt auch mal neue Sicherheitsfeatures haben und es ist jetzt auch nicht so gebaut, dass es die ganze Zeit nervt. Wie bei Vista. Dass sie eben Leute auf diesen Upgrade-Fahrt bekommen haben.
Auf Rüstungspfad.
Und auch im Business-Bereich. Deswegen machen sie halt relativ viel Geld derzeit auch eben mit Windows-Lizenzen. Ich sehe bloß irgendwie nicht so richtig, wie das mit Windows 8 klappen soll. Weil dieses Metro wird sich einfach in... Also das muss jetzt erstmal ein paar Jahre auf dem Markt sein, bevor das im Business-Bereich auch überhaupt nur irgendwie im Ansatz eine Chance hätte, von irgendjemandem für irgendetwas berücksichtigt zu werden, weil die natürlich immer bei ihrem alten Scheißblatt.
Ja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sich das so im Augenblick extrem stark an den Business-Markt verändert. Ich glaube, das zielt auf genau den gleichen Markt, den Apple auch hat. Nämlich Endanwender.
Genau, und dann bin ich mir auch nicht so sicher, ob das so überzeugen wird.
Also ich hab mir, was man hier nicht sieht, also man sieht ja die ganze Zeit nur dieses schöne Metro-Interface und wie das alles ganz hübsch aussieht und zwischendurch. Und das vermeidet er auch wirklich. Da gibt es ja noch diesen Windows-8-Modus. Oder eigentlich sieht er aus wie Windows-7-Modus, wie dein stinknormales, altbekanntes Windows. Und wenn man sich diese Präsentation anguckt, dann hat man das Gefühl, als würde er das nicht sonderlich mögen. Und jetzt haben sich ja diverse Leute ziemlich massive Gedanken darum gemacht, warum ist da überhaupt noch dieses alte Windows unten drunter, wenn er sich das doch eher auf Tablets wendet. Achso, und was sie auch gesagt haben, sie haben gesagt, das wird halt nicht Tablet sein. Das ist jede App, die du dafür schreibst, die muss auch mit der Maus bedienbar sein. Und sie wollen explizit, also es war erwähnt, sie...
Ah, hier das Mikro von diesem Headset unterm Tisch ist eine.
Ich schalte das mal kurz aus.
Also wirklich.
Und das muss alles auch mit der Maus bedienbar sein. Das wird auch auf den Desktop kommen. Das wird auch Tablets werden, auch zusätzlich noch einen Dock haben, wo man sie mit Maus und Tastatur bedient, was ich für relativ schwachsinnig halte. Aber darauf haben die es wirklich angelegt. Das ist sehr betont worden. Und ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum sie dieses sagen. Nein, das ist alles nach wie vor der PC. Weil einfach dadurch, dass, wenn das dann irgendwann nächstes oder übernächstes Jahr kommt, dieses Windows 8, dann wird bei Carstad und bei Saturn und bei Satovac, wo jeder PC, der da rumsteht, wird plötzlich Windows 8 haben. Und die können ihren Entwicklern erzählen, wir haben hier innerhalb von drei Wochen fünf Millionen Metro-User gefunden. Das hat Apple niemals geschafft. Bekommen. So und so viele Millionen begeisterte User. Und ich glaube, das ist die einzige Hoffnung, wie sie überhaupt auf die entsprechende Nutzerbasis kommen. Darum drücken sie das gerade. Also darum wollen sie das unbedingt auch auf dem Desktop haben und auf dem Laptop und auf dem Netbook und überall. Und nicht nur auf dem Tablet. Weil sie ansonsten keine Chance sehen, die Nutzerbasis zu kriegen, damit sich dieses Geschäft für Entwickler lohnt. Klar, die meisten Leute werden es nicht mal wissen, dass sie es kaufen.
Ja, ich glaube auch. Die gehen in Saturn, kaufen sich irgendeine Büchse und da ist Minus 8 drauf, pink. Ja, aber Erna auf dem Dorf, die kauft sich immer noch einen Saturn.
Nee, Erna auf dem Dorf will auch eigentlich einen iPads.
Nein, die einen Drucker anschließen wollen.
Wollen wir deinen iPad einen Drucker anschließen?
Ja, weil ich glaube, diese... Es gibt noch hier noch...
Okay, komm 2012, gut.
Ja, natürlich gibt es noch genug davon. Aber wir reden jetzt hier von einem User-Interface-Wechsel. Benutzer-Schnittstellen-Wechsel.
Ja, aber guck doch mal, das ist doch total toll. Auf der einen Seite hast du sowas, was besser ist als das iPad. Und auf der anderen Seite kannst du immer noch deine ganzen alten Windows-Programme weiterverwenden.
Best of both worlds.
Ja, genau diese Nummer, die nehme ich ihnen einfach nicht ab, dass sie das irgendwie hinkriegen. Dass da wirklich jetzt 1A supergeile Metro-Programme entstehen. Welcher Developer wird sich denn voll auf diesen Metro-Kram stürzen, während einfach die Installed Base noch nicht mal über XP richtig hinausgekommen ist, geschweige denn diesen Windows-7-Upgrade-Fahrt schon auch nur im Ansatz?
Die werden Metro auch für Windows 7 noch liefern. Gehe ich fest von aus.
Haben sie das gesagt?
Das haben sie nicht gesagt, aber sie brauchen die User-Base. Und natürlich kennen sie dieses Problem.
Ja, aber wenn sie Metro für Windows 7 liefern, warum sollten die Leute dann überhaupt auf Windows 8 gehen, wenn der einzige Unterschied zwischen Windows 7 und 8 der ist, dass da Metro dabei ist?
Weil der Colonel irgendwie besser ist und sagt, es ist ja nicht der einzige Unterschied. Es ist ja nur ein sehr wesentlicher Unterschied von sehr, sehr vielen.
Ja, ich hab gar nichts anderes gehört jetzt.
Na ja, die haben den neuen Hibernate-Modus geschrieben. Das bootet wohl irgendwie in unter 8 Sekunden von der SSD. Die arbeiten da auch hinter den Kulissen weiter. Es ist ja nicht so, als ob die da oben so ein bisschen hier mal so bunte Karren draufklatschen und dann nennen sie das Ganze Windows 8.
Also ich bin mittlerweile ein Anhänger des Gedankens, dass das iPad, oder meinetwegen können wir auch von Tablets reden, einfach diese, ich will, dass mein Computer einfach zu bedienen ist, Leute mehr oder weniger vollständig abholen wird. Egal, was du da noch auf deinem Schrott-PC für Vereinfachungen machst. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass dieses, wir machen ein User-Interface, was für Touch und Mouse genauso funktioniert und Keyboard, dass das irgendwie funktionieren wird.
Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, ob es klappt. Also ich bin...
Wenig Hoffnung.
Ich glaube, es ist ihre beste Chance, die sie noch haben. Windows ist ihre Cash Cow und sie müssen irgendwie, und da haben sie diese Marktdominanz und die müssen sie jetzt irgendwie, also sie haben jetzt kapiert, Tablets sind das nächste große Ding. Ich glaube, die denken in die selbe Richtung. Sie sagen, ja, die Leute werden sich Alpads kaufen. Da können sie sich entweder direkt geschlagen geben oder, und das ist ihre Strategie, sie probieren, diesen Wechsel hinzukriegen. Und das ist ihr Versuch, diesen Wechsel hinzukriegen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob er klappt, aber ich würde sagen...
Sie haben MS Paint portiert und es sieht genauso scheiße aus, wie der D&G.
Der sieht halt so ein Metro-Ding. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das Paint ist. Haben behauptet, dass das irgendwer glickhandgeschrieben hätte. Achso, und jetzt siehst du diese Contracts.
Nein, die Leute sehen das gerade nicht.
Die Leute sehen das nicht, du siehst es.
Wieso soll ich dich jederzeit unterbrechen?
Gut, also ich glaube auf jeden Fall, dass das so die beste Chance ist, diese zu haben. Dieses Windows 8. Also sie probieren, die bestehende Userbasis rüberzuziehen. Und ich glaube auch, dass sozusagen das Windows, dass diese Metro GUI, dass die auch auf dem Desktop zu sehen ist, das ist nur um die Zahlen nach oben zu treiben. Das ist meine Behauptung.
Okay, also du weißt, das ist das Beste, was sie tun können. Was wäre, wenn sie was... Also ich könnte mir auch andere Sachen vorstellen. Na warum bringen sie nicht einfach eine OS raus, das heißt Metro? Und das läuft auf Tablets. Und das hat dieses neue User Interface.
Guck mal, wenn die jetzt irgendwann in einem Jahr rauskommen, 2012...
Ich meine, faktisch tun sie das doch. Auf diesen Arm-Tablets ist der ganze alte Windows-Gui-Gram nicht da, wenn ich es richtig mitbekommen hab.
Also sie äußern sich noch nicht so richtig, dass du aber... Das ist dann sozusagen Metro Only.
Und in Metro ist das Ding auch genauso eine geschlossene Box wie iOS.
Aber... Aber jetzt guck doch mal, bei Lion und so ist es doch jetzt genauso. Also wir haben beide einen Darwin drunter, ja. Dann gibt es diese schicke iOS-Uberfläche, die jetzt bei Lion mit Back to the Mac, mit Loungepad und so weiter auch auf den Desktop gekommen ist. Ja, wir haben auch immer noch unsere OS X-Uberfläche, aber wir haben jetzt auch schon so Ansätze von iOS-Interface, Scrollbars und so weiter und so fort.
Ja gut, das sind Anleihen, aber du schreibst nicht ein Programm sowohl für Touch als auch für Mouse. Das tust du nicht. Und das halte ich für einen echten Dealbreaker, weil das ist einfach mal schwierig, etwas für Touch und für Mouse zu schreiben.
Bin ich total bei dir. Also ich glaube, wie gesagt...
Deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob das wirklich... Weil du meintest, das ist jetzt das Beste, was sie tun können. Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, dass das das Beste ist, was sie tun können.
Na guck mal, wenn sie jetzt...
Sie könnten dieses Metro auch schneller fertig kriegen. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie noch einen anderen Quatsch da noch mit dranhängen müssten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich schneller da wäre. Ich sehe, auf dem Tabletmarkt wären sie der fünfte Anbieter. Wobei jetzt mindestens einer schon aufgegeben hat. Vermutlich wären zu dem Zeitpunkt, zu dem sie rauskommt, wären zwei schon aufgegeben.
Redest du jetzt von der Hardware oder redest du von der Software?
Ich rede von der Software. Also das iPad ist da, Android ist da, wir hatten das Touchpad, wir haben noch dieses Rim Playbook, was sich ja offensichtlich überhaupt nicht verkauft. Und dann kommt jetzt als fünft Microsoft.
Nichts verkauft sich, außer dem iPad.
Ja klar, aber als fünfter Tablet OS Hersteller kommt Microsoft.
Ja gut, aber die anderen sind ja auch alle wirklich, also ich meine Playbook, da müssen wir glaube ich echt nicht drüber reden, das ist einfach mal doomed, das wird einfach mal nix.
Ja, aber meinst du nicht, dass ein Microsoft Tablet einen ähnlich einschlagenden Erfolg hätte wie Windows Phone 7? Nämlich gar keinen?
Also ich schätze eigentlich niemanden die Chancen derzeit besonders hoch ein, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass das nicht in so einer Firma auch nochmal zu den Sinnen kommt. Ich meine, sie haben jetzt, in den letzten Monaten war Google wirklich so gekloppt, die haben ihn ja wirklich so zugespielt, durch diesen Kauf von Motorola, das stärkt Microsoft in meinen Augen. Weil sie einfach HTC und ihre ganzen anderen Partner einfach nachhaltig vergraulen werden. Da ist ja auch dieses Dokument veröffentlicht worden, im Rahmen einer gesetzlichen Auseinandersetzung, wo Google so ihre Strategie wiedergegeben haben. Ja, wir müssen hier irgendwie Marktvorsprung für die Hardware usw. Genau das, worüber wir hier eigentlich auch schon diskutiert haben. So, wir killen einfach mal diesen Partymarkt, aber sie trauen sich halt derzeit noch nicht, das auch noch zuzugeben.
Na ja, diese Dokumente waren älter. Die Dokumente waren sozusagen, wie sie mit der... zuerst den Code, zuerst rollen, dann irgendwie den Source-Code schon eine Weile, also erstmal einen Exklusivpartner ausliefern, den Quellcode für eine neue Entsorgung.
Zieht das nicht auch auf Motorola schon?
Ich glaube, die Dokumente waren älter.
Aber da war doch von Hardware die Rede.
Natürlich, geh mit einem Hardware-Anbieter einen Exklusiv-Deal ein für eine neue Version. Haben sie auch immer gemacht, haben sie mit Motorola gemacht, haben sie mit Samsung gemacht, haben sie immer so drei um mit verschiedenen Geräten und dann kriegen die sozusagen exklusiv, müssen sich da für ihn schön beugen.
Genau, jetzt open. Aber jetzt haben sie Motorola gekauft, jetzt ist das natürlich sehr naheliegend. Und selbst wenn sie das nicht tun werden, die Drohung steht im Raum.
Natürlich.
Und ich glaube, die ist bei HTC auch irgendwie angekommen und die könnten halt jetzt sagen, ach naja, da setzen wir dann doch mal lieber auf Microsoft. Weil da haben wir dann auch viele andere Probleme nicht. Ja, da gibt's dann nur ein Store und so. Es ist interessant, also Microsoft folgt sehr viel mehr Apple in einer Hinsicht. Nämlich was sozusagen die Kontrolle über die Plattform betrifft, obwohl sie nach wie vor nur in dem Software-Bereich verweilen wollen und noch nicht selber Hardware anbieten wollen. Andererseits wagen sie sich beim Kopieren dieses Weges, zumindest bei der Software, da eigene Wege zu geben.
Vielleicht kommt ja auch die eigene Hardware mit zu ihrem Gerät. Ich meine, das ist noch lange hin.
Woran ich nämlich immer denke, ist Nokia. Sie haben ja nun diesen Deal da mit Nokia, von dem keiner so genau weiß, was da eigentlich drinsteht. Und gut, vielleicht geht es Nokia echt nur um Telefone. Aber im Prinzip ist es eine Bude, die kann stabile Handhelds bauen. Die haben Kapazitäten und ob die nun irgendwie so groß oder so groß sind.
Die hatten auch dieses zienliche Neck-Book.
Ja, der glaube ich fast überhaupt auch nicht, auch nur beim Ansatz irgendein Erfolg war. Also sie haben das schon mal so probiert. Ich könnte mir das halt auch... Also ich wäre nicht überrascht, wenn Nokia ein Tablet ankündigt, was halt mit diesem Windows-8-Kram dann auch läuft. Ich wäre auch nicht überrascht, wenn HTC und alle anderen Android-Partner, die nicht Motorola sind, da auch mit aufspringen. Von daher hätten sie durchaus schon eine Chance, zumindest den zweiten Platz mal anzugehen.
Ja, aber sie wollen nicht Zweiter werden, weil sie wissen, dass sie als Zweiter keine Chance haben. Also guck mal, wenn das...
Ja, aber da gibt es glaube ich derzeit keine Alternative. Also die nächsten zwei Jahre gibt es einfach nur den zweiten Platz. Der erste ist nicht zu holen.
Naja, aber wie gesagt, wenn sie in einem Jahr damit rauskommen, dann gibt es, dann sind zu dem Zeitpunkt 50 Millionen iPads verkauft, die auf dem Markt sind. Das ist ein Vorsprung von 50 Millionen Geräten, den Apple hat. Und die einzige Chance glaube ich, die sie sehen, dass sie diesen Vorsprung auch über längerfristig wieder aufholen können, ist, dieses Metro GUI muss auch auf dem Desktop. Weil das ist der einzige Hebel, den sie haben.
Aber der Desktop ist doch dokt.
Naja, er ist nicht so tot, dass da nicht in den nächsten 5-6 Jahren nochmal ein paar hundert Millionen Geräte verkauft werden.
Der wird ein paar hundert Millionen?
Keine Ahnung insgesamt. Ist mir auch ehrlich gesagt, ich will jetzt nicht über irgendwelche Zahlen diskutieren, sondern das ist ihr Hebel, den sie haben. Sie haben den Desktop-Markt unter Kontrolle und sie müssen diesen Desktop-Markt jetzt dazu bringen, dass er die Transformation auf das Tablett vorbereitet. Weil das ist ihre einzige Chance. Sie können nicht bei Null anfangen, weil dann haben sie schon verloren.
Also dieser PC mit Tastatur-Markt schrumpft.
Ja, aber er ist riesig.
Naja, aber er schrumpft.
Das kriegen sie ja mit, darum müssen sie jetzt ja schnell weg da.
Buckel, sag du mal was.
Also wie gesagt, ich finde das ist...
Ich bin bei diesen Themen immer nicht so... Ist nicht so meins.
Aber können wir mal was anderes nochmal aufgreifen aus diesem ganzen Kram, ne? Diese, die ich jetzt richtig gelesen habe, in Metro Only, also alles, was Metro ist, gibt es keine Plugins. Alles hat ja fünf.
Flash ist raus.
Alles ist in Big Four, there is no Flash. Ich glaube jetzt nicht, also ich glaube noch nicht, ich sehe das noch nicht, dass die Stückzahlen hier eine Rolle spielen, aber die Botschaft ist natürlich auch klar. Also wir wollen es nicht mehr haben.
Das ist ja das Lustige daran.
Ich wollte auch nochmal von meinen Erfahrungen berichten.
Bei diesem Windows, wo ich auch so einen totalen Pferdefuß dabei sehe, ist dieser Windows Desktop. Und wenn er wirklich auf Tablets drauf sein wird, dieser Windows Desktop zusätzlich, und du hast...
Kann er ja gar nicht.
Wir können ja auch ein Intel Tablet rausbringen.
Eine Maus hat noch eine Tastatur davor.
Per Stift?
Zum Ausklappen natürlich.
Die Developer-Geräte, die...
Bluetooth-Tastatur, Bluetooth-Maus.
Entweder das, ja klar, das kannst du natürlich alles machen. Oder bei den Developer-Geräten, die sie jetzt umgeschickt haben, da war dann auch ein Stift dabei. Dann konntest du rüber switchen auf die Windows-Oberfläche, dann hast du ein komplettes Windows gehabt mit einem Pipapo, und das konntest du per Stift bedienen. Ja, und das ist jetzt halt so... Und was da das Lustige ist, es gibt halt den Internet Explorer in dieser Metro-Oberfläche, und es gibt den Internet Explorer in einer normalen Windows-Oberfläche. Das heißt, es kann sein, dass du so ein Tablet kaufst und zweimal einen Internet Explorer hast. Und der eine davon kann Flash, weil der unter dem normalen alten Windows läuft, was Flash kann, und der andere kann kein Flash, weil er in einer neuen Metro-Oberfläche läuft. Und zum einen, glaube ich, wird es das vom Verkauf kompliziert machen, weil wenn die Leute in einem Laden stehen und sich für so ein Windows-8-Tablet interessieren, dann wird der Verkäufer natürlich probieren, denen irgendwie das Intel-Tablet zu verkloppen, mit dem X86-Prozessor, weil die werden wahrscheinlich ein bisschen teurer sein, weil die auch größeren Akku brauchen und höhere Kosten haben und so was. Und er wird ein tolles Verkaufsargument haben, nämlich guck mal, da läuft der Internet Explorer auch mit dem Flash drauf. Kann ich da auch Firefox installieren? Ja, da können sogar Firefox installieren. Firefox auf dem Tablet funktioniert ganz hervorragend. Und dann kaufen diese Leute und sind unglücklich mit und schmeißen sie in die Ecke. Aber Microsoft hat mir wieder ein Gerät verkauft und Hersteller.
Ich glaube, das wird alles nichts mehr werden.
Ich glaube, wir haben lange genug über dieses Microsoft geredet.
Ich glaube auch.
Besser sagt ihr, ich hab ja gar nicht da drüber geredet. Na, was heißt keine Meinung? Ich beobachte das halt mit Interesse, wie sie sich das halt so alles denken und wie sie es da so versuchen. Aber mich spricht es jetzt persönlich auch nicht direkt an. Ich find's halt ganz nett, dass sie auch mal ein anderes Interface wählen und es sieht auf jeden Fall ein bisschen schöner aus als dieses. Als dieses Android-Gefrickel und so, ja. Und so von dem Interface, was man so bisher von allen anderen gesehen hat, finde ich jetzt auch gar nicht schlecht. Aber mich spricht es persönlich nicht an. Und diese Dualität und so weiter und die angesprochenen Punkte hier mit Maus und Touch und so, ja, glaube ich auch nicht so dran. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass ich mich Tag ein Tag aus jetzt damit befassen möchte. Und eigentlich sitze ich so da und harre der Dinge, die kommen und bin froh, wenn die Apple-Jungs es schaffen, besser zu machen. Und nicht wie jetzt hier und da zu fühlen ist, aber es auch ganz schnell bergab geht mit der Apple-Qualität.
Bei den Eröffnungen von Apple Stores.
Apple Stores, Geräte, Betriebssysteme, Kalender-Software. Also, ja, nein, also ich hab jetzt, also, ja, nee, dieses iCal in Lioness-Scheiße, das kann ich jetzt auch schon bestätigen, aber wir müssen jetzt nicht nochmal eine halbe Stunde drüber reden. Aber ich hab jetzt auch, weil ich jetzt irgendwie von Tim ja früher oder später doch überzeugt wurde, je länger er immer darüber spricht, dass so, eindring, also, es sickert ja dann doch durch die Hirnrinde irgendwann, ähm, hab ich ja auch nochmal geschaut so im App Store. Es gibt auch wirklich nichts an Kalender-Software, nichts. Also wirklich nicht mal im Ansatz, nur diese komischen Menübar-Applikationen. Erstaunlich, also ich wiederhole einfach nur noch die Forderungen aus den letzten 25 Sendungen. Schreibt doch mal eine Kalender-Software, kann eigentlich nicht so schwer sein. Punkt. So, und jetzt kommen wir zum spannenden Teil des Abends. Die schönen Mac-Neuigkeiten, ne? Der letzten zwei Wochen. Tim Cooks ehemaliger Job wurde wieder besetzt. Ich hab nur gelesen, dass Tim Cooks alter Job wieder besetzt wurde. Und da dachte ich ja an unsere alte Sendung, wo du ja meintest, wird gar nicht neu besetzt und das war eigentlich schon der De facto-Zustand, aber jetzt haben sie sich gedacht, haben sie unseren Podcast gehört und dachten, hm, Mist, es ist wieder ihm was aufgefallen. Müssen wir schnell was machen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wovon du redest, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hab irgendwo gelesen, dass Tim Cooks Job neu besetzt wurde.
Also ein COO gibt es nicht.
Mist, jetzt willst du bestimmt quälen wissen, ne?
Ja, also es wurde mal über denjenigen, der sich sozusagen jetzt vor allem um das kümmert, worum er sich vorher vor allem gekümmert hat, geredet. Ich hab diesen Namen jetzt schon wieder vergessen, aber er hat nicht spezifisch diese COO-Rolle eingenommen, sondern er war halt, was weiß ich, Vice President of Operations oder sowas. Und die sind ja dann auch nicht auf diesem, in diesem Inneren, Inner Cirque.
Inneren Kreis.
Ach, und übrigens hier fehlt mir dann auch gerade noch ein, wenn wir schon von letzter Sendung sprechen. Hat auch jemand schon im Chat angesprochen, du hast ja auch immer noch deinen MacBook Air 11 Zoll. Letztes Mal war es dir ja noch irgendwie zu laut oder so.
Ja.
Ist immer noch so, aber du hast es noch nicht verkauft.
Nee, ich hab, also sagen wir mal so, ich hab, ich könnte halt natürlich, hab mein anderes noch nicht verkauft, aber ich brauch schon die 256 GB. Also es war halt vorher ein bisschen knapp und ich bin zwar, was so die Wärmeleistung dieses Gerätes und den Lüfter-Einsatz betrifft, nicht so glücklich, aber wenn man die Kiste jetzt nicht zu sehr tritt, dann geht's auch.
Naja, was heißt denn, ich bin nicht zu sehr tritt? Also wir kennen ja unsere Benutzer-Patterns. Musst du dich denn dabei einschränken oder?
Ich kann das jetzt so im einzelnen System auch immer sehr schwierig mit dieser ganzen Zauber. Du weißt ja auch jetzt schon bei Line überhaupt nicht mehr, was überhaupt noch läuft oder was nicht schon automatisch beendet wurde oder so. Von daher ist das wirklich sehr schwierig zu beurteilen. Und so Zeit für ausführliche Benchmarks, wo das dann im Detail bei rauskommen würde.
Mir fällt es eigentlich immer nur auf, wenn ich, sobald ich Flash anmache und hier bei meinem Arbeitgeber mal das ein oder andere Spiel starte, dann ist immer sofort der Lüfter an. Und die CPU bei 100 Prozent immer.
Ja, mit Flash ist es ein bisschen schlimm. Ich meine, ich benutze ja keinen Flash auf diesem Computer eigentlich. Ich habe nur den Google Flash Player installiert, wenn ich halt mal was sehen muss. Wobei mir das eben für meinen Geschmack immer noch zu häufig ist. Also diese viele Webseiten, das nervt mich wirklich. Viele Webseiten könnten mir problemlos voll HTML5-Video-Content liefern. Tun das auch, wenn ich sage, ich bin ein iPad. Tun das aber nicht, wenn ich sage, ich bin kein iPad, aber ich habe trotzdem keinen Flash. Das ist echt absurd. Das ist echt schade, aber es ist halt auch Gewohnheit, viele Leute embedden einfach immer noch nach demselben Muster, wie sie es schon immer gemacht haben. Und packen halt einfach nur Flash rein. Gerade so diese kleinen Gems. Und manchmal ist es schon wirklich anstrengend, dass du nicht so Full-Web kriegst. Weil dir ja auch manchmal einfach was entgeht. Also kriegst du irgendwie so einen Link, ja hier guck mal. Und dann so, ja.
Sind nur Kommentare.
Fünf Zeilen Text, genau, mit Kommentaren. Und du siehst halt gar nicht, dass da irgendwas ist. Schwierig. Also es ist schon, es ist noch sehr schwierig, ohne Flash wirklich, ohne Verluste durch den Tag zu kommen. Aber was den Lüfter betrifft, hilft das auf jeden Fall.
Das auf jeden Fall, ja. Wobei, ja nee. Also eigentlich, komischerweise ist es bei mir im Firefox auch am schlimmsten. Also im Chrome und im Safari, wenn es jetzt eben nicht gerade ein Flash Spiel ist oder irgendwie so, dann geht's noch. Aber beim Firefox hab ich das Gefühl, sobald ich irgendwas auch nur ansatzweise mit Flash angucke, frisst der sich den Ramp voll und die CPU und alles wird langsam und es beginnt zu riechen. Na ja, gut, also dein MacBook Air bleibt. Darf drin bleiben.
Ja, ja, ich äh, vor allem wenn ich es in so einem definierten Modus habe beim Podcasting, ist nicht so, weil es auf einmal so aus dem Nichts aufheult.
Apropos übrigens Webbrowser und Extensions und Plugins, kommen wir immer zu einem heiteren Thema. Kommt vielleicht eine kleine Produktempfehlung, die eigentlich gar kein Produkt ist, sondern Open Source vielleicht sogar am Ende. Es gibt ja immer so ganz viele Leute, die gerne total auch anonym surfen wollen und ungetrickt von Google Analytics und wie sie nicht alle heißen. Also da gibt es ja wirklich unzählige. Und letztens hat der Denis, der jetzt ja nun gerade nicht da ist, also glaube ich kurz nach unserer Sendung sogar, so eine kleine Safari-Extension ausgebuddelt namens Ghostree. Ich paste das am besten nochmal hier gleich in den Chat, damit auch alle sich nicht verzippen müssen. Mist, wo muss ich denn jetzt hier Ghostree da kopieren? Paste. Geisterei. Geisterei, genau. Und die sorgt dafür, sie hat halt so eine Liste mit irgendwie 638 von diesen Tracking-Services, also da ist wirklich eigentlich alles dabei, also sämtliche Ad-Netzwerke und so weiter und so fort. Und auch wenn jetzt hier gerade einer im Chat sagt, ewig alt, ich kannte die noch nicht. Und hab die jetzt mal seit einer ganzen Weile schon im Einsatz, eigentlich seit der letzten Woche, als Denis das getwittert hat. Und find das ganz cool, weil du siehst halt rechts oben bei jedem Seitenaufruf, welche Tracking-Netzwerke jetzt gerade geblockt werden. Du kannst irgendwie auch, wie bei AdBlock, sagen, hier bei der Seite erlaub mal DoubleClick, weil jetzt nun gerade dieses Video bei IMDB nur abspielt, wenn du DoubleClick zulässt und so eine Geschichten.
Hört auf Facebook dann auch dazu?
Also du kannst, genau, diese ganzen Facebook-Widgets, alles, was so potentiell dich über Dritte trackbar macht. Ja, also es ist ja auch das, was halt auch viele wahrscheinlich gar nicht so realisieren, was jetzt hier in unserer technischen Community, sag ich mal schon, aber zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt hier mit Kunststudenten mich unterhalte oder sonst wem und erzähle hier, dass Google Analytics dich auch trackt, ohne dass du was dafür tun musst oder eingeloggt sein musst, finden auch erst mal alle spektakulär. Und davon gibt es halt tausend andere Netzwerke. Und ich hab ja schon seit eh und je sämtliche Google Hosts zum Beispiel in meiner ETC Hosts nach Local Hosts zeigen lassen, damit die Schnische trackt werde. Und noch so ein paar andere Bekannte, aber zum Beispiel diese ganzen Facebook-Kram, diese ganzen Ad-Netzwerke, gut, die werden halt jetzt von meinem Ad-Blocker noch geblockt, aber Social Networks gibt es ja auch noch genug. Und mit Ghostery habe ich das jetzt gefühlt, zumindest erst mal alles geblockt, fühlt sich ja auch das Web gleich ein bisschen snappier an. Also so das Rennenring, weil halt das ganze Geraffel, auf das man sonst halt immer beim Seitenladen wartet, erst mal gar nicht am Start ist. Das ist schon ganz cool. Also ich hatte halt erst so ein bisschen Angst, ok, 638 irgendwie Tracking-Netzwerke und mal sehen, ob das performt oder langsamer wird, aber naja, wurde es erstmal nicht. Also wie gesagt, mein Eindruck ist snappier. Also wie gesagt, einer im Chat meinte schon alt. Es gibt es übrigens auch für die allermöglichsten Browser. Ich glaube, Firefox, ja hier auf der Seite, alle Major-Browser sind wohl dabei. Von daher ist das jetzt auch nicht nur so eine Mac-User-Safari-Geschichte, sondern da sind, da können alle mitmachen.
Fein, ja ich hab auch noch so ein kleines Web-Game. Ähm, Moment, da ist es. Ich hatte die Webseite schon mal hier gebracht, aber die Jungs sind immer wieder fleißig, neue Dinge erfinden. Und zwar everymac.com. Ein hervorragendes Verzeichnis von so Macintosh Specs. Also die ich auch schon wirklich seit vielen, vielen, vielen Jahren verwende, die immer mal wieder mit neuen Sachen hochkommen. Und jetzt haben sie die Ultimate Mac Sword rausgebracht. Ähm, die Ultimate Mac Sword ist so, ich suche bestimmte Macintosh Modelle auf Basis bestimmter Eigenschaften. Also sowas wie, welche Computer können noch Mac OS 9 fahren? Welche Computer haben Gigabit Ethernet eingebaut? Und alle möglichen Kombinationen da draus. Also kannst du Mindestanforderungen, Maximalausbau von RAM, ja, also welcher Computer hat so und kann 8 GB RAM fressen, hat so und so viele Expansion Slots, benutzt diesen Prozessor, etc. Clockspeed, auch so Details, wo man vielleicht häufiger nicht so nachschaut, aber auch so kann ein zweiter Bildschirm angeschlossen werden in einem bestimmten Modus, ja, also mindestens mit Mirroring oder halt auch mit Dual Mode und Mirroring, etc. Und das kann man alles damit machen.
Das ist irgendwie nice.
Schon mal nicht schlecht, ich hätte zwar jetzt wahrscheinlich in meinem Leben bisher noch nicht wirklich viele Anwendungsfälle dafür gehabt, aber trotzdem ganz cool zu wissen, dass es das gibt.
Das ist vor allem so, wenn du dir denkst, ich hätte jetzt hier eigentlich ganz gerne auch so eine Maschine, die das und das macht.
Kannst du eigentlich mal leiser tippen, Max? Mit Gefühl.
Sonst hast du immer ein iPad dabei.
Heute hab ich auch jetzt dabei. Oder kann ich dich so schnell drauf tippen?
Aber leiser.
Ja, Anwendungsfälle.
Ja, was weiß ich. Angenommen, du weißt, ich will einen Mac Mini haben. Weil der soll für mich das und das und das machen. Aber wenn du auf Ebay schaust nach alten Mac Minis, da, wisst ihr wie das ist, da verkaufen Leute einen Mac Mini, der ein bisschen älter ist. Man weiß ja nicht ganz genau, welches Modell und ob das Modell jetzt wirklich genau das kann, was du brauchst. Und angenommen, du willst auf jeden Fall einen Mac Mini haben, der den und den Port hat, der den und den RAM Mindestausbau hat, weil du weißt, so viel brauchst du halt, der eine bestimmte OS-Version auch fahren kann. Und dann kannst du es halt mit so einem Tool erstmal auf diese Geräte, ganz konkret diese Modelle, reduzieren und dann eben strategisch Ebay nach solchen Sachen abklappern, beziehungsweise die Leute explizit fragen mit, was ich, gib mir mal die letzten drei Stellen von deiner Seriennummer, weil die kannst du ja auch bei dem Ultimate Lookup bei Everymac eingeben und dann siehst du ganz genau, ist das jetzt auch so ein Gerät, was meiner Suche entspricht. Dann ist man dann ja auch mal schnell dabei mit so einem Schnäppchen. Dann kannst du vielleicht, was ich, vielleicht mal für 100, 200 Euro genau das Gerät finden, was dir jetzt weiterhilft, ohne dass du eben jetzt ein neues Gerät kaufen musst. Oder ein sehr viel neueres zumindest als das.
Meine Empfehlung, Everymac.
Es ist ein Wunder, dass sich solche Webseiten überhaupt refinanzieren können. Aber es scheint zu funktionieren. Die Jungs sind schon seit Ewigkeiten...
Haben auch keinen Flatterbutton? Vielleicht sind die ja von irgendetwas. Aber sie haben einen Google plus Like-Button. Plus eins.
Plus einsen. Die haben immer noch Themen. Ah ja, Security Error. Habt ihr das mitbekommen? Ein krasser Bug ist in Lion. Ich wollte es ja zuerst nicht brauchen.
Dieser Älter?
Nee, aber es ist wirklich, es ist echt ein bisschen finster.
Dass man sich mit Passwort einloggen kann?
Nein, du kannst ohne, also wenn du bei irgendjemanden, also wenn du an einem eingeloggten Rechner bist, das ist sozusagen die Bedrohungssituation, die schon mal da sein muss. Also es geht nicht um Einbruch in. Wenn jemand eingeloggt ist, normalerweise kannst du ja nicht das Passwort ändern, ohne das alte Passwort noch mal einzutippen.
Mit Line geht das aber.
Mit einer Kommandozeile. Indem du direkt über den Directory-Services-Klimbim gehst, kannst du dann, also sie haben irgendwas mit den Shadow-Passworts und den Zugriffen da drauf, haben die geändert und ich hab's ausprobiert und es geht. Also brauchst du hier nur was eingeben, es gibt hier einen längeren Artikel, ich link da drauf.
Aber du hast jetzt nicht gehört, dass du Bugdans jetzt so gab.
Na ja, ist schon, also...
Damit kannst du auf jeden Fall eine Menge Ärger machen. Du kannst halt Leuten mal eben on the fly das Passwort unterm Arsch wegdrehen.
Und dich dann damit einloggen und im Zweifel ruht sein.
Ja, das ist ein höllisches Problem, aber sie hatten ja auch noch diesen schönen Bug, dass wenn du über LDAP verbunden warst, dass du dich mit jedem beliebigen Passwort anmelden konntest.
Ist das schon gefixt?
Na ja, gab es ein Update. Also, ich sag ja, es geht bergab mit Apple. Seit Steve hustet.
Na ja, was heißt es geht bergab? Also auf der anderen Seite ist Line auch eine extreme Verbesserung, was sie sich halt betrifft.
Eine extreme Verbesserung.
Na ja, wenn dann so eine Gurken drin sind, dann kann man das doch wieder in Frage stellen.
Sollte man vielleicht auch. Wir stellen das in Frage. Wir prangern das an. Finden das nicht gut.
Ja, sie haben noch hier irgendwie erst groß getönt von wegen hier einen neuen Security Officer und jetzt von der NSA, alles ganz speziell und spezial. Und dann kommt da sowas raus und sie haben plötzlich vergessen in ihrem Release die richtigen Privileges auf dieses Shadowfile zu setzen.
Genau.
Dachten sie jetzt, ach jetzt wo wir Full-Disc Encryption haben, sind wir sicher.
Ja, wenn das die hübschen Mädchen rauskriegen.
Die hübschen Mädchen? Wann machen die dann?
Die zeigen auf uns auf dem Schulhof.
Wir, die wir den Apple mögen.
Auf die hübschen Mädchen interessiert das überhaupt nicht, ob man mit einer Kommandezeile Passwörter ändern kann.
The times they are a-changing. Piraten kommen in Landesparlamente und ich sag dir, mit so einem gehobenen Nördturm im Balsverhalten muss man auch rechnen demnächst. Schon so ist das ja richtig akut, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Mit den Passwörtern?
Date Symbole und so weiter. Man will ja nicht gehänselt werden. Genau, also kann man ja jetzt nicht auf so eine Plattform setzen, wo man dann die ganze Zeit so ein Hänselpotenzial hat. Ich meine, mit Windows bist du einfach mal unattraktiv.
Ja, meine Freundin sagt schon hier, dass hier iCal und so, das fühlt sich an wie Windows und was ist denn los?
Ja, genau. So, und dann gibt es einfach mal zwei Wochen kein Sex mehr.
Mindestens. Nee, und Tim vor allen Dingen.
Oh Gott, bei Tim hängt die Sex-Häufigkeit davon ab, wie gut Eichholz ist. Das spricht nicht für deinen Sexuallee, tut mir leid. Deins, du hast es doch gerade gesagt. Aber das erklärt, warum man so extrem wie vor Kalender herziehen kann.
Jetzt hast du auch noch von den Kollegen gehänselt. Aber eigentlich meinte ich ja, Tim guck...
Ich lecke einfach in die Zukunft. Jaja, das führt jetzt echt zur Verwirrung, ne?
Oder Cookie Dent und Tim Plath.
Gut.
Die Themen geben mir aus.
Ich wollte noch Zeichenprogramme. Zeichenprogramme.
Aber du musst sie vortanzen, wie in der Waldorfschule.
Mach mal.
Du wolltest nicht jedes Treter installieren müssen und dann hast du mal geguckt, es muss doch was anderes geben.
Nee, so fing es nicht an. Ich will ein paar Alkons bauen und hatte dann angefangen, die in Pixelmater zu machen. Pixelmater ist nett, aber ist nicht so richtig gut. Ich probiert die in Photoshop zu machen und Photoshop ist mal so richtig scheiße. Man hat, weder man Photoshop nutzt, sehr viel Zeit, sich über Photoshop auszuregen. Das ist, ich hab, es gibt, also einer dieser Bugs, die da drin ist, der ist wirklich, es gibt diese Hilfslinien, die dafür da sind, damit wenn man eine Auswahl macht, zum Beispiel, dass die Auswahl genau an diesen Hilfslinien snappt. Also die kann man den ganzen Zeit sehen, die sieht man dann, und dann schnappt so dieses Werkzeug da ein. Außer du zooms voll rein und dann passiert Folgendes, dann schnappt diese Auswahl überall ein, außer an diesen Hilfslinien. Also dann hast du eine Hilfslinie gesetzt, um pixelgenau deine Auswahl setzen zu können und dann verhindert Photoshop, dass du genau auf diese Hilfslinie das draufsetzen kannst. Und es geht einfach nicht mehr. Und es treibt dich total in den Wahnsinn. Du musst anfangen, deine Hilfslinie einen Pixel daneben zu setzen, weil es ansonsten nicht mehr funktioniert. Ich weiß nicht, und ich weiß, dass dieser Bug kein neuer Bug ist, sondern dass er sich schon seit einigen Major-Versionen in Photoshop rumtreibt.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn sie den Fixen beschweren, sich dann die Designer, die sich schon dran gewöhnt haben.
Wieso geht das jetzt plötzlich wieder richtig? Bei Flash aufregen können wir alle schöne Zeit machen. Aber nutzt mal irgendwie hier zwei Tage Photoshop und ihr werdet wirklich wahnsinnig...
Oder Illustrator oder alles andere. Das ist ja alles schlimm geworden.
Auf jeden Fall hat mich dann Toto draufgebracht. Naja, er macht Icons immer mit Omni Graffle. Dann hab ich mir mal so eine Demo-Version von Omni Graffle runtergeladen und Omni Graffle Pro ist auch ganz hübsch. Die Standardversion würde mir nicht ausreichen. Die kann zum Beispiel so Elemente beschneiden. Also dass man zwei Objekte übereinander legt und dann sagt, schneide das Innere aus dem Äußeren raus. Das kann nur Omni Graffle Pro. Und das ist scheiße teuer. Ich weiß nicht, was kostet das? Über 100 Euro auf jeden Fall. Also wirklich so eine Summe, die schon durchaus weh tut, wenn man nur hin und wieder mal einen Icon bauen will. Und dann wird ja jetzt gerade im App Store so massiv Eye-Draw beworben. Das kostet irgendwie nur 20 Euro. Und wenn ich wüsste, dass es... Ja, was kostet die? 199 Dollar, 200 Dollar, die Professional-Lizenz. Und dieses Eye-Draw wird beworben, was jetzt 20 Euro kostet, aber ich fürchte auch nicht, das kann, was ich will. Und jetzt hab ich mir mal Draw-It runtergeladen. Und das macht eigentlich einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Das ist Draw-It aus dem Apfel-Store.
Das gibt's auch im Apple-Store. Das kann man sich aber auch als 30 Tage Demo runterladen bei denen und kann da auch die Vollversion kaufen. Und die haben da so ein zweites Vektor-Zeichenprogramm, das heißt Sketch. Das sieht sehr, sehr ähnlich aus, ist aber ein bisschen anders, was ein bisschen doof ist, weil sie sollten mal lieber ihre gesamte... Ich glaub, das sind nur zwei Entwickler, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Naja, aber ich mein, dann könnten sie ihre gesamte... Also sie sind offensichtlich... Draw It ist ein sehr schönes Programm, ist aber im Detail nicht ausgereift.
Ich hab mir das auch schonmal angeguckt, ja.
Und anstelle jetzt einfach mal zu sagen, hey, wir machen das jetzt mal so richtig rund, fangen sie noch ein zweites an. Das ist dann irgendwie, was sehr, sehr ähnlich ist, aber auch ein bisschen anders. Aber ich glaub, es kostet irgendwie 30 Euro und ich glaub, die werd ich dann mal ausgeben, weil vielleicht geb ich da sogar für, es gibt eine Bundle-Version aus Sketch und Draw it, aus beiden, dann kann man so, kann man in beiden feststellen, dass er genau das Feature, was man gerade braucht, wieder nicht haben und dann kostet es irgendwie 60 Euro oder irgendwie sowas. Aber das ist, die haben so ganz schicke, was ich an Photoshop echt nett finde, sind so die Ebenen-Effekte. Also dass man so irgendwie malt eine Ebene und dann kann man so verschiedene Effekte drauflegen und sowas in der Richtung haben die da auch für Vektoren und das macht eine Menge her. Und ich hab ungefähr, ich bin dann...
Du kannst auch so Emboss machen damit?
Ja, du kannst Schatten drunter legen, du kannst...
Schatten ist ja...
Du kannst alles Mögliche, Inner Shadow, du hast hunderte Effekte, du kannst auch...
Interessant, ja das Problem hatte ich nämlich auch.
Die haben auch so schöne Sachen wie das hier zum Beispiel vor dem Export kannst du ein Dokument zerschneiden. Also wenn du so irgendwie eine Webseite draus machen willst oder... Slices. Oder auch ein Xcode im Interface-Bilder wenn du möchtest oder das irgendwie nicht als Bild brauchst, sondern als... Dann kannst du die Slices anlegen, kannst sagen hier das wird das Dokument und das wird das Dokument und dann macht er das alles automatisch für dich.
Versteh ich das hier gerade? Versteh ich das richtig? Man kann sagen, also man hat zwar eine Vektor-Zeichnung, aber man gibt dann irgendwie eine Auflösung, für die man targetet an.
Genau.
Und kann dann auch so reinzoomen und dann sieht man auch die Pixel. Und dann wird die wie es auf den Pixel gerendert werden.
Das ist übrigens eine der größten Scheichen von Illustrator.
Ja, genau.
Und das ist was, was Photoshop eigentlich können sollte, aber den letzten Versionen eben nicht mehr schafft. Das ist das, was mich so in den Wahnsinn trat. Ich will nichts anderes als Pixelbilder bauen und Pixel genau damit arbeiten.
Kann man das Teil auch so einfach mal einen PDF aufmachen und seine Bestandteile zerlegen?
Keine Ahnung, hab ich nicht probiert.
Weil das war nämlich, als ich neulich nach einer Software suchte, die Hauptanforderung. Hab ich letztes Mal schon erwähnt, oder? Hab ich nicht erwähnt? Warte mal, wie heißt ja noch mal gleich dieses Tool, was ich benutze? Weil ich nämlich auch OmniGraphel, ich hab auch OmniGraphel Pro gekauft. Und das Problem bei OmniGraphel ist auch, dass es eben, man merkt, dass es eigentlich kein, es ist kein Grafiken-Konstruktions-Tool. Sondern es ist ein Sketching-Tool mit Organisations, oder noch besser, es ist eigentlich ein Org-Chart oder organisationsartige Diagramm-Zeichner, ein Diagramm-Zeichner mit Zeichen-Funktionalitäten, die sehr ausgereift sind. Und da das eben von Omni kommt, kann man damit schon relativ weit gehen. Aber wenn man jetzt wirklich in die Details von Logo-Erstellungen etc. möchte, da ist es dann eben auch schnell vorbei. So, dann hab ich mir eine andere Software rausgekickt und jetzt fällt sie mir verdammt nochmal gerade nicht ein.
Wo ist der scheiß Teil?
Guck doch in deine zuletzt benutzten Programme.
Vektor Designer heißt es.
Stimmt, hatten wir aber doch glaube ich schon.
Hab ich schon erwähnt, ne?
Genau.
Für Vektor Designer gilt genau das, was du eben auch von der anderen Software gesagt hast und ich glaube, es gilt wirklich für alle diese Programme. So, es ist an manchen Stellen nicht so richtig bis zum letzten Ende durchgedacht oder fehlerfrei, dass du wirklich immer mal wieder in solche Check-Ups hineinläufst. Aber immerhin, und das war für mich extrem wichtig, du kannst mit Vektor Designer einfach PDFs öffnen und in seine Bestandteile zerlegen. Das heißt, wenn du ganze Seiten hast und du willst da irgendwie nur so ein Logo-Element oder irgendeine andere Konstruktion herausnehmen und du willst sie aber dann eben wirklich als Vektor beibehalten und alles was du hast ist dieses PDF, dann ist das eine relativ günstige Methode das PDF zu lesen. Das ist so eine der Stärken von Illustrator, dass PDF ja sein natives Speicherformat ist.
Speichern die native PDF?
Also da steht zwar Punkt AI dran, aber es handelt sich um PDF. Du kannst eine beliebige PDF-Datei in Illustrator ziehen und er öffnet das exakt genauso wie AI. Beziehungsweise du kannst eine AI-Datei abspeichern und kannst es einfach in PDF-Viewer kippen und siehst es so. Sie haben dann noch eine ganze Menge an Metadaten, die sie dann eben noch mit abspeichern, die jetzt so von normalen PDF-Viewern nicht weiter beachtet werden. Also Text, die dann eben für das Editing wichtig sind. Aber grundsätzlich hast du da an der Stelle schon mal die Interoperabilität. Und Vector Designer war jetzt eben eins der Tools, die ich gefunden habe, bei denen das eben gut funktioniert, mit dem PDF-Öffnen. Hatte auch schon Fälle, wo es irgendwie nicht so richtig geklappt hat. Es gibt dann immer wieder diese Konfusion, dass du einfach das ganze geladene Konstrukt hast und dann irgendwie nicht in seine Bestandteile mehr weiterzulegen kannst. Also, du musst in der Regel öffnen und dann angruppen, bis zu einem bestimmten Level. Und ich hatte das auch schon mal, kann es jetzt aber gerade nicht wiedergeben, inwieweit das nachvollziehbar war, dass eben dieses Ungrouping nicht ging. Aber es kann dann auch wieder ein Bug in der Dot-Dot-Release gewesen sein und jetzt ist es vielleicht nicht mehr so.
Ja, das ist halt auch irgendwie so ein bisschen bei diesem ganzen Bildbearbeitungs- oder Grafikprogramm auch alles so mit dieser Halbfertigkeit dramatisch. Also was Photoshop ja leider bis heute noch als einziger macht, ist ja zum Beispiel, dass die Disziplin Bildbearbeitung eigentlich so relativ komplett abdeckt. Also war ja ursprünglich mal so die digitale Version der Dunkelkammer. Deswegen sind ja auch die ganzen Werkzeuge mehr oder weniger eins zu eins der analogen Repräsentanz entsprechend. Habe ich letztens auch in der Dunkelkammer selbst erlebt, wie man so mit Dodge und so das in Analog halt macht. Ja klar. Also da merkt man dann auch so, dass dieser Bezug zur eigentlichen Dunkelkammer in Photoshop sehr stark ausgeprägt ist. Und diese ganzen Sachen, die halt zur Foto- und Bildbearbeitung da drin sind, die sind halt so auch in keinem anderen Ding. Also nicht in Pixelmater, nicht in Acorn, nicht in sonst was. Und bei Vector sieht es halt auch irgendwie so ein bisschen ähnlich aus. Also Illustrator ist halt echt so buggy bis ins Letzte. Und es wird mit jeder Version schlimmer. Und Freehand ist ja damals die gelobte Zeit, das gelobte Land. Naja, aber so diese ganzen Tools, auch bei Vector, da fehlt immer so die letzte Ecke mal. Irgendso ein Tool ist dann doch nicht da oder es hat so komische Bugs. Also ich hatte eins von diesen Drawed oder Sketched oder so, hatte ich auch mal eine Bucke, weil ich dachte, okay, komm lass jetzt den Illustrator, wir brauchen nur was ganz Einfaches und dann scheitert du das an irgendwelchen Bizierkurven, also wirklich so an diesen grundlegenden Sachen, wo dann irgendwelche Sachen rumflippten und plötzlich, wo ziehst du an einer, an einen dieser Anfasser und die Bizierkurve fliegt dir da auseinander. Das ist echt dramatisch und da ist auch so ein großer Markt da und so viele dankbare Leute wären da, die da irgendwie...
Ja, aber das ist auch so, ich meine, die sind so eine kleine Bude und kriegen es darum nicht fertig. Und auf der anderen Seite hast du Adobe, die sind so eine Riesenbude und kriegen es darum nicht fertig.
Ja, da ist was Wahres dran, Max, da ist echt was dran.
Und es wird auch immer alles bloatiger und fetter oder eben nie über so ein gewisses Stadion hinaus. Und es ist halt auch echt erstaunlich, also dieses Photoshop, wenn man sich das mal so anguckt, so die Version 3, 4, 5 und so, wie cool die damals schon waren. Ja, und die konnten richtig doll fielen. Du konntest damals schon einfach auch professionell damit richtig loslegen, in den frühen Versionen. Und hier, der hat jetzt auch 3.0 Draw-It und so.
Also mit Tix, mit dem Photoshop muss ich sagen, ich hab das jetzt irgendwie, wir haben das jetzt gemietet. Habe ich das erzählt? Wir haben das gemietet. Genau. Und das ist, man kann die deutsche Version, die kostet, ich glaube, 70 Euro im Monat, und die englische Version kostet 50 Euro im Monat. Auf derselben Webseite verlangt ihr tatsächlich 20 Euro mehr für die deutsche Version. Und dann habe ich das erste Mal seit, ich weiß nicht, wie vielen Jahren, Photoshop aufgehabt. Und es ist, man sieht es und man möchte wirklich, also das ist, man möchte direkt auf die Tastatur kotzen. Die haben so einen, der Cursor, der Wartecursor, der ist keine Uhr mehr, wie er früher mal war, und er ist auch kein Beachball, sondern es ist so dieses, dieses, wie heißt dieses Progress Rad, dieses Spinning Wheel, also dieses drehende Rädchen, was man auch vom iPhone kennt, haben die als Cursor, und zwar nicht als transparent, sondern einfach so flatsch, so sieht es aus wie ein großes Animated GIF, was sie so als Cursor verwenden. Und diesen Cursor siehst du ab sofort immer, weil Photoshop einfach wirklich bizarr langsam ist. Das fährt hoch, das macht ein Dokument auf, irgendwie ein 200 Megabyte Dokument, und der Prozessor, der Rahmen ist nicht voll, der Prozessor dümpelt irgendwie bei 20 Prozent hin.
Das SSD.
Das SSD ist schnell, an der Kiste ist alles schnell, also jetzt zumindest schnell genug, um ein Photoshop-Dokument aufzumachen. Und es braucht irgendwie fucking 20 Sekunden, um so ein däniges Dokument aufzumachen. Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum. Ich weiß nicht, was sie tun, damit das so langsam wird. Ich hab es wirklich so gehasst. Es ist nur schlimm. Und früher war mal...
Hamburg-Haffenstraße. Da stehst du und blickst auf den Fluss, wo so kleine Sportboote rumflitzen. Kommt da so ein riesiger Tanker, der sich da so durchschiebt und es dauert einfach alles ewig.
Ja, so dieses Gefühl.
Ja, aber dann nicht pixelgenau auswählen können. Ich meine, das ist doch...
Du weißt, dass ihre Gui mittlerweile Flash ist, ne? Das ist so traurig.
Das ist echt. Und die Dialoge sind...
Dass sich da auch keiner rantraut, das irgendwie mal.
Ja, also das beklagen wir auch schon seit langer Zeit.
Ja, wo wir schon beim Beklagen sind, ich glaube, ich wiederhole mich, ja.
Kalender, Audio?
Nee, jetzt ganz konkret, ne? Dieses Problem. Also ich suche schon seit Jahren, ne? Also ich hab Photoshop... Ich hab nie so richtig viel gemacht in Photoshop, aber damals war es ja so der Pixel-Editor, den hatte man einfach nur so auf der Platte, ne? Und jetzt hab ich das aber schon lange nicht mehr, weil ich das meinem Computer nicht zumuten will, diese Adobe-Pakete. Gute Wahl. Ja, also das ist wahrscheinlich der beste Raubkopierschutz, den sie je hatten. Das ist ja ein User-Interface. Und es gibt genau eine einzige Funktionalität in Photoshop, die ich schon immer total beeindruckend fand. Sowas einfaches und ich verstehe nicht, dass es kein einziges Pixel-Tool kopiert bekommt. Und das ist einfach der Image Resize Dialog. Du kannst, wenn du den immer in Photoshop aufmachst, ist dir einfach sofort klar, also du kannst alle, die typischen Wünsche sind, ich möchte diese Grafik gerne haben in dieser Pixel, in dieser Pixelzahl mit dieser Auflösung. Und dann kannst du in Photoshop irgendwie genau immer anklicken, was miteinander verlinkt sein soll, dass der Aspekt-Ratio hält und dass das sich nicht ändern soll und das sich nicht ändern soll.
Pixelmeter crash gleich mal, als ich versuche, das danach zu verziehen.
Und mit Archorn und mit Pixelmeter, also das fängt schon so, was weiß ich, bei Archorn, das fängt schon immer damit an, machst dann so Image Resize und dann hast du dieses Feld, wo du die Pixel angibst und dann steht da nicht der Ist-Zustand drin, sondern irgendeine andere Pixelzahl.
Also bei Pixelmeter hatten sie das am Anfang auch. Was ich bei Pixelmeter am Anfang total vermisst hat, wenn man ein neues Dokument aufmacht, dann ist Photoshop schlau genug, von vornherein in die Höhe und Breite, den aktuellen Inhalt der Zwischenablage einzutragen. Also wenn man ein Bild in der Zwischenablage hat, dann wird das automatisch gemacht. Das hat Pixelmeter am Anfang auch nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt. Schaffen sie jetzt aber schon seit einer ganzen Weile. Ich finde diesen Resize-Dialog übrigens bestenfalls so mittel.
Ja, aber so ein paar Sachen. Also ich benutze ja Photoshop sehr häufig als Farbselektor tatsächlich auch. Weil dieser Color-Selektor, der bei Apple Default ist, da kriege ich zum Beispiel die Kratzer, und das benutzt der auch Pixelmeter und so weiter. Ich benutze Photoshop seit Version 2.5 und dieser Color-Selektor hat mich...
Aber es gibt doch garantiert irgendwie einen Plugin für den Color-Picker, der so Photoshop macht.
Ja, man hört auch mit Plugins in diesem hässlichen, verkackten Color-Selektor von Apple. Das ist wirklich auch eins der allerletzten Dinge in diesem OS. Der ist so scheiße. Du kannst ja nicht mal die Hexzahl ohne Plugin von deiner Farbe da rauskriegen oder irgendeine sinnvolle.
Stimmt, das geht in Photoshop. Wobei in Photoshop hat er über Jahre hinweg das Problem gehabt, dass er dir einen Null-Byte hinten an deinem... Du hast es kopiert und er hat dir einen Null-Byte hinten dran gehängt. Und das hast du dann in deinem Text-Editor genommen und dann hat dir der Internet Explorer die Seite nicht mehr richtig gereinnert. Kannst du dir den Spaß vorstellen, rauszukriegen, woran das hängt?
Also das ist hier diese einfache Image, Resize-Dialog von Photoshop und ich kann das jetzt gerade nicht mehr... Ich müsste das mal wieder so vor mir haben, wenn ich das schon länger nicht mehr gehabt habe, aber da konnte ich einfach immer meinen Wunsch richtig formulieren, ob ich einfach eine bestimmte Größe haben möchte oder zum Beispiel gib mir... Ich möchte gerne, dass das Dokument am Schluss 10 cm... Genau, das ist nämlich die Hauptanwendung, dass es so 10 cm breit ist und diese Pixel-Auflösung hat, nämlich 300 dpi. Und jetzt rechne mir mal aus, wie viele Pixel das sein müssen und dann Zack, return. Das kannst du in diesem Fotoshow-Dialog genauso eingeben. Ich möchte gerne, dass du jetzt resize, ich möchte gerne, dass das Endergebnis bedeutet, dass es 10 cm breit und es 300 dpi ist. Das geht nicht mit Pixelmeter, das geht nicht mit Archorn, das geht auch mit sonst nichts. Und ich kann das nicht verstehen, weil das ist doch einfach mal die...
Na ja, es geht schon in Pixelmeter mittlerweile auch.
Geht es in Pixel?
Ich hab ein paar ablässliche mitbekommen. Der Dialog sieht anders aus, aber du musst halt sagen, es sieht ähnlich aus wie bei Photoshop. Jetzt hast du auch oben dieses Fit into.
Mehr ist schon anders als bei Photoshop.
Oben zeigt er dir an, wie viel das Original ist, wie viel das hinterher wird. Dann kannst du hier sagen, ich will 10 cm breite. Bei der Auflösung kannst du sagen, hier Scale oder nicht Scale, Resample oder nicht Resample und...
Aber hier kannst du noch die Document Size...
Das konkret, was ich jetzt gerade gesagt habe, das hat sich aber verändert jetzt.
Die sind da schon nach wie vor dran.
Wobei ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich nicht mehr die Hauptanwendung.
Warte mal, vielleicht haben sie das ja jetzt hinbekommen und ich rede nur Stuss.
Die meisten wollen wahrscheinlich...
Ist das hier auch so ein, dass ich hier...
Nur Screen Design machen, so wie ich zum Beispiel.
Also normalerweise sind halt diese ganzen komischen Presets da, aber die hattest du ja da gerade auch ausgewählt.
Okay, alles klar. Entschuldigung. Dann hat sich das wohl geändert hier. Das müsste ich mal...
Also ich hab ja auch Pixelmater seit geraumer Zeit, weil ich so immer die Hoffnung habe, dass ich von dieser Adobe-Grütze erlöst werde von irgendjemanden. Pixelmater sah lange Zeit so aus, als hätten sie zumindest in diesen Photoshop-Funktionalitäten noch die Nase vorn, aber...
Ich glaub, ich muss mir mal Pixelmater kaufen.
Da gibt's ja dann auch die Version 2... Lassen sie mich durch, ich hab eine Kreditkarte!
Ich kaufe ja ein.
Meine Kreditkarte ist scharf.
Ja, also ich hab so mit, was du jetzt sagst, so mit... mit... mit so, um von Adobe mal loszukommen und so was. Das ist... das genauso ging es mir auch. Und das macht so ein bisschen... also ich musste dann durch Schmerzen durch, ehrlich gesagt. Es ist schon eine ganze Menge... wobei es auf der anderen Seite... du hast mal plötzlich so ein Grafikprogramm, was einfach... du startest, es ist so eine Star und du warst nicht irgendwie eine Minute drauf, dass es jetzt irgendwann mal einsatzbereit ist.
Aber wie gesagt, so in bestimmten Sachen ist es halt leider immer noch unersetzlicher.
Vielleicht sollten wir mal die anonymen Adobiker starten.
Ich bin trocken! Ich bin trocken!
Ich kann auch ohne!
Aber du hast doch neulich wieder Illustrator aufgehoben. Das war nur eine Ausnahme!
Ich hab aus Versehen auf ein E-File geklickt.
Das war der Feind da.
Genau. Ich war's nicht. Das war nur der Feind da.
Aber warum hast du es denn überhaupt installiert?
Wobei ich sagen muss, dass jetzt Photoshop dann wieder zu installieren, das hat schon gerade auf diesen schönen neuen MacBook Air ein bisschen dreckig angefühlt. Ne, erscheinlicherweise überhaupt nicht. Es braucht ja keine Rechleistung.
Das ist einfach nur langsam.
Also das ist einfach nur Weight-Cycles oder was?
Ja, die Sleeven zwischendurch wahrscheinlich regelmäßig einfach mal ein bisschen länger. Weil das der User so erwartet. Ich hab keine Ahnung warum.
Ich hätte so gerne einen Adobe Photoshop 5.0 auf diesem Gerät. Das wär so schön.
Aber guck mal, sie haben diesen unglaublichen About-Dialog. Ich meine, da haben sie offensichtlich eine eigene Abteilung für, die nichts anderes macht, als mit jeder neuen Version irgendwie neue About-Dialoge zu bauen, die dann animiert und achtdimensional im luftleeren Raum existieren. Und ooooh.
Ich hab übrigens, wo wir gerade schon bei so Programmchen sind, ne? Ich hab ja letztes Mal, hatte ich ja dieses Chocolate-App erwähnt und irgendwie hatte mich ja einer zu Meckwim und so weiter angesprochen und dann hab ich mir ja tatsächlich ich hab jetzt in den zwei Wochen so ein bisschen dieses Chocolate-App probiert und hab nochmal mein Wim-Setup rumelaboriert und dann hab ich mir nochmal die anderen Editoren angeguckt und jetzt, weil wir auch letztes Mal nochmal über dieses Sublime Text 2 gesprochen hatten oder ich hatte es zumindest auch erwähnt als eine der... Genau. Bin ich ja jetzt total gerade doch tatsächlich diesem Sublime Text verfallen.
Wirklich? Du wechselst aber auch deinen Text-Editor häufiger als die Unterhose, oder?
Nee, nicht ganz.
Wie Text-Mailtuse das so machen?
Du weißt, dass man das jetzt so und so verstehen kann.
Alle 5 Jahre.
Das ist bewusst offengehalten. It's left as an exercise to the listener. Da reiße ich mir schon das Headset hier mit dem Fuß vom Kopf.
Man spricht Deutsch, ja?
Also, man spricht Deutsch.
Das ist ja nicht einfach hier mit diesen Fachbegriffen. Da sind dann unsere Hörer auch total verwirrt.
Was war jetzt der Fachbegriff?
Nein, das ist englische Colour-Wilch.
Soll ich jetzt Sublime Text übersetzen? Oder Text-Editor? Nee, was denn? Was hab ich denn in Englisch gesagt?
Sprich weiter.
Genau, also. So ein kleiner Überblick. Ich weiß, Max, du bist IDE-Benutzer. Deswegen jetzt mal nur für die Text-Editor, Freunde, die Text-Editorn zum Programmieren benutzen.
Freunde, die langen Tipparbeit.
Von mir aus auch das. Also, eure Alternativen sind ja aktuell, ja. Also abgesehen von dem Schwergewicht BB-Edit und vielleicht dem etwas leichteren Text-Bringler, also die Urgesteine der Text-Editor-Liga. Dann gibt's ja noch sowas wie Smule-Tron, ein einfacher Text-Editor mit ohne Features oder mit sehr wenigen. Dann gibt's auch noch so einen in der ähnlichen Kategorie. Und dann fängt es ja so langsam an, dass das mittlerweile auch sehr betagte Text-Mate fällt auf durch bedienbare Leichtigkeit oder Leichtigkeit in der Bedienung. Also kommt ja...
Leichtigkeit des Seins.
Leichtigkeit des Seins, genau.
Und eine häufige Präsenz des Beachball-of-Days.
Ja, Moment, da kommen wir gleich zu. Also Text-Mate, als Text-Mate rauskam, war ja schon irgendwie cool. Haben ja die ganzen Ruby-Developer vor allen Dingen gehackt, weil David Heinemeyer-Hansen mit der Kermit-Stimme Screencast gemacht hat und allen Text-Mate gezeigt hat. Und hat ja mit wenigen Tastendrücken plötzlich Snippets, Klassen und alles Mögliche aufgefaltet. Und ich muss auch sagen, noch in der Retrospektive, so zum Beispiel HTML editieren, hat mir ein Text-Mate extrem großen Spaß gemacht, weil es gab einfach so ein paar Shortcuts, Rap-Selection in Text oder weißt schon, einfach so Katsching und du hattest irgendwie so dein HTML-Dokument an der Backe. Und auch so das mit den Snippets und so, alles super. Dann, wie Max schon sagt, spinning Beach Boy of Death. Also wenn dann mal die Skripte doch ein bisschen länger als 100 Zeilen wurden oder so, oder man mal ein Feind im Project mit 1000 Zeilen oder noch mehr machen wollte, dann war Text-Mate ganz schnell am Ende. Dann gab es so ein paar Erweiterungen dafür, mit denen man das vielleicht noch ein bisschen lindern konnte, aber dann crashte es auch viel häufiger und irgendwie wird es ja auch nicht weiterentwickelt und der Zug des 21. Jahrhunderts ist für Text-Mate irgendwie so ein bisschen abgefahren. Was jetzt die ganzen Mac-Programmierer und möchte-gern-Programmierer getan haben, die sind ja auch zu Herrscharen zu MacWim gewechselt. Haben sich sozusagen auf die Graubärte zurückbesinnt und gedacht, Mensch, der MacWim, der sieht ja eigentlich auch nicht schlecht aus und eigentlich benutzen das ja auch die Graubärte und das ist ja eigentlich ganz cool und man kann ja auch alles damit machen. Und noch viel mehr. Und über die Zeit haben sie sich ja mantra-mäßig selbst davon überzeugt, dass MacWim eigentlich viel cooler ist als TextWim. Zumindest sehr viele davon.
Unter anderem ich.
Ich hab ja jetzt auch MacWim benutzt.
Und?
Bei mir hatte das vor allen Dingen den Grund, dass mit MacWim hast du halt einen Editor, der auf dem Server im Terminal genauso funktioniert wie auf dem Desktop. Also wenn du dich einmal mit diesen Commands und so weiter angefreundet hast, dann kommst du halt auch auf jedem Server klar, weil ein VI ist eigentlich immer installiert. Oder, Tim, du als erfahrener Unix-Benutzer, der schon alle Unix unter diesem Horizont benutzt hat, gab es mal eins, wo kein VI dabei war?
Ich scheitere bis heute daran, Emacs und VI überhaupt zu beenden. Ah, jetzt hat er VI gestartet! Wie komm ich jetzt wieder raus? Ach, so einfach! Nennen wir den Podcast rum. In eskapedoppelpunkt Q.
Ich könnte jetzt nochmal so eine Oper erzählen von Kriegkommentaren dazu machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du doch auf ihn auswolltest.
Vielleicht gleich. So. Naja, aber mit Wim habe ich mich jetzt durchaus auch angefreundet und konnte das auch benutzen. So, allerdings, so richtig happy war ich damit jetzt auch nicht. Und dann habe ich ja letztes Mal hier Chocolate-App angeschaut oder auch verbreitet.
Beziehungsweise uns darauf hingewiesen, dass es da eine Beta gibt.
Mich haben sie nicht genommen. Eine Alpha. Hier, die haben mir vorhin im Chat die Invites rumgeschickt.
Ich möchte auch einen Invite.
Also zu Chocolate-App muss man sagen, das ist halt wirklich, wirklich noch Alpha. Also die kommen mit einem recht coolen Interface daher und es ist schon erkennbar, dass sie vielleicht auch in die richtige Richtung gehen. Aber es ist noch so früh und sie haben noch so viele Features nicht. Sie haben kein Vertical Select. Sie haben kein Right Margin Indicator. Sie haben irgendwie kein Autocomplete. Sie haben kein Klammern Highlighting. Sie haben nichts eigentlich.
Aber was haben sie denn überhaupt?
Sie haben Split View, was ja viele bei den klassischen Texteditoren vermissen, die mit den üblichen USX-Mitteln sozusagen daherkommen, um Text darzustellen und zu Highlighten und so. Split View ist eben so ein Feature, weswegen halt viele zu Vim und EMAX vielleicht noch gegangen sind. Aber dieses Chocolate hat das. Und zum Beispiel Jump to File, was halt auch Textmade eigentlich so populär gemacht hat. Also drückst halt Apfel T. Fängst an mit Fuzzy Search irgendwie deinen Feilnamen zu tippen, den du jetzt öffnen möchtest. Fuh Bar Controller und fängst halt an mit Fuh zu tippen. Und dann ist er schon gleich oben, drückst Enter und pengst deinen Feil offen, ohne jetzt irgendwie durch irgendeinen Baum zu navigieren oder sonst irgendwas.
So wie Launchbar oder Spotlight.
Genau, Launchbar für den Editor sozusagen. Ja, also es hat schon ein paar Sachen, aber es hat halt einfach sehr viel was zum Programmieren, wirklich benötigt wird nicht. Also dann kannst du auch wirklich gleich Textedit benutzen. So, in etwa. So und dann, wie gesagt, gibt es halt auch schon seit längerem eben dieses Sublime Text und ich hab das mir in der Version 1 angeguckt und das war hässlich und das war doof und ich mochte es nicht. Und jetzt hab ich einen Kollegen letztens nochmal gesehen und wir hatten ja es hier auch eben nochmal angesprochen und dann beim Kollegen sah es plötzlich eigentlich gar nicht so scheiße aus. Auch wenn die Seite jetzt auch nicht sonderlich hübsch ist, aber genau. Dann ist ja das erste Ding, was so dem geneigten Mac-User auffällt. Moment, das ist ja Cross-Plattform.
Oh ja, das hat mir auch Angst gemacht.
Das geht für OS X, Linux und Windows. Holy shit, wie soll das nur einigermaßen funktionieren? Auch der Screenshot auf der Seite ist ein Windows-Fenster und natürlich ist der Mac-User da erstmal angeekelt und wird sich gleich wieder abwenden. Wenn man es dann aber doch mal runterlädt in der Version 2 vor allen Dingen, stellt man fest, dass es gar nicht so schlecht ist. Also dafür, dass es wirklich eine Cross-Plattform ab ist, ist die extrem gut eigentlich integriert. Also was ich ja letztes Mal schon angesprochen hatte, hier Apfelkomma für die Preferenz, das geht nicht. Da kommt man schon mal ins Naserumpfen. Also die Konfiguration von diesem Editor läuft hauptsächlich so wie bei Vim über Config-Files, muss man schon mal so sagen. Ja, aber... Ja, es ist so ein Zwischenwesen. Zwischen TextMate und Vim könnte man fast sagen.
Oh, das Eigen ist ja schön.
Aber jetzt wo ich den halt irgendwie das ganze Wochenende schon benutzt hab und heute den ganzen Arbeitstag über, muss ich sagen, der hat auch extrem coole Features. Also er hat halt so diese Editier-Leichtigkeit von TextMate, zum Beispiel HTML, also diese ganzen Sachen, die du in TextMate zum Snippets und HTML editieren lieben gelernt hast, die funktionieren da auch schon mal cool. Fuzzy Search geht, Project Find ist schnell, die TextMate-Themes funktionieren und die TextMate-Language-Files und man kann auch diese da reinschieben und editieren und erweitern, was halt schon mal ein... Weißt du, wenn du deinen Lieblings-TextMate-Theme schon hast, peng, hasse das.
Oh, haben die auch mal ein Themeball, was schwarz auf weiß ist? So ganz klassisch?
Haben sie auch, ja. Irgendwo ist das. Und sie haben echt so fast BB-edit-like-Features für Text-Selection. Also du fährst deinen Cursor irgendwo hin und kannst dann mit verschiedenen Mitteln deinen Scope expanden. Zum Beispiel, wenn du Abfüll- oder Ctrl-Space drückst, dann sagst du Expand Scope und er versucht immer, die nächsten Scope-Delimiter zu finden, um deine Selection zu erweitern. Das heißt, ohne dass du irgendwas nochmal anfassen musst, bleibst auf der Tastatur, haks einfach nochmal zweimal drauf und schwupp hast du nicht nur das Wort, sondern alles, was in Anführungszeichen steht.
Wie wird man den Scope-Delimiter auf Deutsch? Ja, Scope ist schon noch was anderes. Da wird es immer echt schwierig. Wie soll man sowas in Deutsch finden?
Geltungsbereich. Also der Geltungsbereichtrenner.
Wie ja?
Der Bereichs-Trenner. Und ihr wundert euch, warum wir immer so viele englische Begriffe verwenden.
Es ist halt nicht so einfach in der Informationstechnologie.
Klingt gut, könnte man auch mal auf seine Visitenkarte drauf schreiben.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und wissen Sie, ich bin Geltungsbereichtrenner.
Und wie sind Sie damals aus dem Dünnenbereich wieder rausgekommen? Das klingt doch gar nicht so alt aus. Die Sendung würde 6 Stunden dauern, wenn wir alles auf Deutsch sagen würden.
Zum Beispiel in Wim gibt es ja eben auch diese coolen Features, wo Leute schon regelmäßig staunen, wenn man sowas macht wie Select Inside. Und dann kannst du irgendein Zeichen tippen und er benutzt das als Begrenzer für deine Selektion. Also wenn du sagst C, I, Anführungszeichen, dann selektiert er alles, was in den nächsten Anführungszeichen ist, die er so antrifft. Und solche Geschichten. Und das geht halt auch in Sublime und diesmal mit benutzerfreundlichen, leicht merkbaren Shortcuts und nicht mit irgendwie C, Doppelpunkt C, I, W oder sowas. Ja, Change, Insight und dann das...
Und wenn drei, du musst aber nicht am Anfang stehen dann sozusagen.
Ah, die haben echt ein paar süße Sachen.
Echt, das geht?
Also in Vim, nicht in VI glaube ich. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es auch in VI geht, ehrlich gesagt, weil ich VI nicht mehr benutze. Also ich benutze immer Vim, aber...
Ich bin ja so ein totaler mega VI. Hardcore-User gewesen.
Also ich muss ja sagen, das hat hier einige schöne Sachen. Also diese Command-Palette zum Beispiel, sehe ich das richtig? Das ist eine... Wenn man Apfel-Shift-P drückt, dann geht eine Palette auf, in der man alle Befehle sieht, und zwar so, dass man auch direkt anfangen kann zu suchen.
Genau, das ist halt auch, es kommt auch aus TextMate sozusagen, und das ist auch bei TextMate so gewesen, und halt total schick, und dieses Fuzzy Search auch schön. Also es hat wirklich...
Aber bei TextMate war das immer so, dass man, wie war denn das, da musste man noch irgendwie noch, da hat das nur bei einigen Befehlen funktioniert, oder irgendwie sowas. Ging das dabei ein? Oder nur bei diesem externen Bundle-Zeug?
Weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht so genau. Aber, also, ich muss halt echt sagen, ich hatte auch so meine Zweifel, aber ich find's echt ziemlich gut, und er ist extrem snappy, also, was mir bei McWim irgendwie aufgefallen ist, im Vergleich zum Beispiel zu Sublime Text, also Sublime Text, da ist alles wirklich so BAM, Snap, Instant da. Und es macht auch Spaß. Und ich hab halt, ja, weiß nicht, diese Minimap ist schon auch cool, auch wenn die eigentlich relativ begrenzte Nützlichkeit hat, aber diese Minimap an der Seite bei manchen Codefiles hilft das schon auch zu finden, wo man eigentlich hin will.
Also das ist so eine Übersicht mit, wenn man jetzt die gesamte Datei sieht.
Ja, und ich, also ich könnte mir vorstellen, tatsächlich jetzt auch mal eine Zeit lang als mein Default-Editor zu benutzen. Ich werde es jetzt auf jeden Fall mal eine Woche oder länger tun. Bis jetzt hat mich auf jeden Fall noch nichts dran genervt. Und es ist halt schon benutzerfreundlicher als so ein McWim. Weil bei einem Wim musst du echt, auch wenn du den anpassen willst, musst du dich in diesem Wim-Skript beschäftigen. Und da gibt es zwar tausend, also du kannst alles einstellen, du kannst jedes Plugin haben, was du haben willst, aber...
Die Schriftauswahl ist relativ begrenzt. Es gibt zwei Befehle, nämlich Larger und Smaller.
Du kannst halt, wie gesagt, dieses Konfigurations-Fall ist auch viel freundlicher als in Wim. Also es gibt halt dieses Default Settings-Feld und da sind alle Options drin, die es überhaupt gibt und du kannst das dann sozusagen in deinem User-Config-Fall überschreiben. Und da gibt es halt auch so coole Features, die ich in Wim zum Beispiel liebe, bei jedem Speichern automatisch die Leerzeichen von Zeilenenden zu entfernen. Gibt es da einfach so als leicht lesbare, gut kommentierte Optionen, kopiert man sich in seinen User-Config-Fall, schreibt auf true und fertig ist die Laube. Trim, Automatic, White Space und so genau. Genau und...
Ach doch, das macht echt niemanden her.
Muss ich mal glaub ich wieder mit Editoren beschäftigen.
Genau, also der zugänglichste und doch sehr umfangreiche Sublime Text 2 bietet sich da doch an, finde ich. Und der Modus da ist, du kannst den glaube ich gratis benutzen, allerdings so ähnlich wie bei Launchbar alle 25 Saves oder so, kommt mal so ein Dialog hoch, wo du dann mal wegklicken kannst oder sagen, ach kauf jetzt die Scheiße.
Was ich ja echt ganz putzig finde, ist, wenn man hier dieser Datei editiert, ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel den Font gewechselt und wenn man jetzt in eine andere Größe eindrückt und speichert, ist sofort die Änderung übertragen. Das ist, man sieht quasi...
Genau, das macht es eben dann auch cool. Also nicht irgendwie neu starten oder ein neues Dokument aufmachen, sondern wirklich und vor allen Dingen ich so als kleiner Typografie und themen-penibler Mensch habe auch, also ich dachte erst so zum Beispiel, oh Gott, man kann den Zeilenabstand nicht einstellen. Nein, kann man doch, da gibt es, also die Option heißt halt Line Padding Top und Line Padding Bottom. Du kannst sogar einstellen, wo dein Space zwischen den Lines sein soll. Und also alles, was ich so bisher einstellen wollte, konnte ich einstellen und deswegen gibt es da jetzt eigentlich erstmal noch nichts dran zu meckern.
Kann man so space, kann man, kann ich ja auch irgendwie das Theme von der Navigation, also von den Tab da, von der Tab bar ändern? Das ist ja mal wieder schwach.
Mein Theme, das auch dann Text-Made-kompatibel ist, das poste ich auch die Tage mal, aber ich muss das noch für die von mir favorisierten Programmiersprachen ein bisschen anpassen, also ich muss noch bei HTML etwas tunen. Ich habe es jetzt für Erlang, Ruby und JavaScript bisher modifiziert, weil es hier schon Einzelne im Chat fragen, kommt aber demnächst. Schreibe ich bestimmt auch noch einen Blogpost zu und dann ist alles klar. So viel jetzt erstmal so als kleiner Editor-Abriss.
Super. Ich finde es ja erstaunlich, wie du dich da reinschmeißt an die Front. Ich glaube, ich war schon ein bisschen faul. Ich habe irgendwann mal den Sprung zur Text-Made gemacht und bin seitdem dabei geblieben. Ich finde es total frustrierend, dass dieses Projekt so furchtbar eingeschlafen ist, nachdem es so mega vielversprechend gestartet ist. Das ist jetzt irgendwie wirklich das Duke Nukem Forever.
Habe ich jetzt voll in den Kanal genießen, aber es ging zu schnell.
Tut mir leid. Ja, aber ich nutze es vor allem als XML-Editor. Und da, also weniger so als Code, sondern mehr eigentlich, also HTML und aber auch eben extrem viel XML. Und da habe ich eigentlich auch noch überhaupt gar keinen Editor gefunden, der das Leben mit XML wirklich signifikant einfacher macht. Das ist blöd. Das ist auch schwierig, weil man ja nicht mehr davon ausgehen kann, dass das alles, in dem Moment, wo man editiert ist, ist es ja potenziell immer kaputt. Das heißt, du kannst nicht einfach sagen, jetzt hier mit 1000 Dreiecken zum Aufklappen, aber allein schon mal ein wirklich gutes Folding zu machen, das gelingt Text-Mate nicht und das habe ich jetzt auch so noch irgendwo anders gesehen.
Bei Sublime hast du halt diesen Geltungsbereich, Scope Indicator, Scope Indicator, also du hast halt, wenn da so eine Klamme aufgeht oder so ein neuer Bereich anfängt, dann ist da so eine ganz zarte graue Linie, die dann genau bis zum Ende dieses Bereichs geht und wenn du halt so ganz viel geschachtelt hast, dann hast du auch, also das ist sehr dezent. Die immer so da ist, während du mit dem Cursor durchläufst. Genau und damit kannst du dann auch immer relativ schnell sehen, wo du jetzt überhaupt hin musst und es gibt halt diese Commands springen jetzt so close, ich meine das gibt's in Text-Mate auch aber, dadurch finde ich das echt ganz angenehm zu benutzen.
Das ist cool, weil solche kleinen subtilen Dinge, das bringt's.
Aber gibt es denn so vernünftige Editoren, die auch so Schemes auswerten können, XML Schemes und dann eine vernünftige Autocompletion haben? Ich bin ja ein großer freund, ich tippe ja, ich hasse es ja zu tippen und ich mag immer Autocompletion und ich will die immer haben und...
Also bei Schemes setzt das bei mir ganz aus, weil ich noch nie so richtig angefangen habe Schemes zu benutzen, aber ich könnte verstehen, dass man das haben wollen würde, aber das würde ja überhaupt schon mal einen XML-Aware-Editor voraussetzen.
Ja, also... Gibt es bestimmt einige, die das können. Eclipse kann es garantiert, aber ich meine, es hat dann wahrscheinlich genügend sonstige Drawbacks.
Hier wird gerade Espresso empfohlen.
Also ich habe auch mal so diese ganzen Mini-Idees wie Espresso. Also Espresso ist... Die hatten mal früher ein Programm, das hieß CSS-Edit, das habe ich geliebt. Also für CSS-Dateien ist das die selbe Bude. Das ist die selbe Bude, genau. McRabbit oder so heißen die.
Und gibt es nicht mehr CSS-Edit.
Das ist jetzt quasi, also ich weiß nicht, ob es das noch gibt.
Ist Espresso das?
Aber Espresso ist mehr als nur das. Aber es ist nicht so gut.
Es hat schon eine Web-Developer-Idee quasi, aber...
Und dann gibt es ja hier noch Coda von Panic, was jetzt auch nicht schlecht ist, aber das ist so wie bei den, was wir vorhin bei diesen Zeichenprogrammen, Malprogrammen hatten. Da fehlt doch an einigen Punkten noch mehr, viel zu viel, als dass das wirklich richtig geil funktionieren soll und sowas.
Also es ist vielleicht so für Einsteiger, keine Ahnung, gut, aber da fehlen einfach echt viele Power-Features und auch so dieses Syntax-Highlighting, was die so an den Tag legen, das finde ich bisweilen echt dünn. Also wie gesagt so Scope-Highlighting und Klammern-Highlighting und diesen ganzen Krempel und so, da muss halt richtig schnell snappy und zuverlässig funktionieren und irgendwie bei diesem Coder und Espresso und so, weiß nicht, habe ich mich nie so richtig wohl gefühlt.
So richtig doll ist es nicht.
Vor allen Dingen, weil ich auch wirklich nur einen Bruchteil von der Funktionalität brauche. Also das kommt noch hinzu.
Ja und die Funktionalität ist dann auch nicht so... Also ich meine, man hat da ein Coder, hat man aus irgendeinem Grund, hat man ein Terminal eingebaut, so eine kleine Shell, mit der man dann direkt mit dem entsprechenden anderen Server verbunden ist. Ich hab ein gutes Terminal, ich brauch das da drinnen nicht. Also es ist... und das sind so echt Sachen, die so... naja, das geht besser. Also es ist... da fehlt doch... also so wirklich toll ist das alles nicht. Ein guter JavaScript-Editor. Also ich komm immer nur wieder drauf zurück hier auf dieses...
Aber man kann festhalten, dieser Bereich ist in Bewegung. Also da tut sich was. Es ist nicht so eine so eine bekloppte Stagnation, sondern eigentlich gibt es eine ganze Menge Alternativen.
MobileMax stellt fest, dieser Bereich ist in Bewegung.
Also ich bin auch sehr gespannt, was die Chocolate-App-Jungs so noch bringen. Also momentan, so die bringen zwar alle zwei, drei Tage ein neues Bild raus, aber da tut sich verhältnismäßig wenig. Also wie gesagt, diese elementaren Features wie Vertical Select und so. Also, dass man Spalten selektieren kann. Gibt's nicht und so. Weiß ich nicht, ob sie das schaffen.
Aber dieses Vertical Select, das ist bei TextMate, man kann dann auch diese ganzen Zeilen alle auf einmal bearbeiten. Das ist tatsächlich ein sehr hübsches Feature.
Also hier in Sublime Text kannst du das entweder auch mit der Maus machen oder du kannst sogar in Sublime hier selecten und dann hier oben auch noch. Ich weiß zwar nicht genau, wie das funktioniert.
Also mehrere nicht zusammenhängende Bereiche gleichzeitig auswählen und an möglichst vielen Stellen. Was ich ja bei Xcode ganz hübsch finde, ist, ich kann mir den Shortcut Command-Ctrl-E, glaube ich, was, da taucht manchmal neben variable Namen auf, dass du jedes Aufkommen dieser Variable innerhalb des aktuellen Dokuments bearbeiten kannst. Also sozusagen so ein Suchen und Ersetzen direkt in Dokument. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Deshalb PHP Storm auch, erstaunlicherweise.
Übrigens für die, die MacWim benutzen, also eine Sache, die mich an MacWim total geätzt hat, also abgesehen von diesem Insert Mode und nicht Insert Mode, die ich nur so halb cool finde, in MacWim funktioniert ja nicht Ctrl-E und Ctrl-A und so, sondern da muss der mit der Karotte oder mit dem Dollar-Zeichen zum Zeilenanfang oder Zeilenende springen. Und das ist schon echt ein bisschen nervig. Und in eigentlich allen normalen Editorien kannst du halt Ctrl-E und Ctrl-A zum und so weiter benutzen, das ist ein Sublime halt auch. Deswegen finde ich den auch gerade cooler als MacWim. Der ist irgendwie zu anders, der Wim. Als Desktop-Editor.
Ich nutze ja mittlerweile, das ist ja echt lustig, ich benutze zum Coden, früher habe ich alles mit BB-Edited. Ich habe auch Blog-Artikel mit BB-Edited geschrieben und habe immer alles mit BB-Edited gemacht. Und mittlerweile zum Schreiben von längeren Texten nehme ich einen gesonderten, also nehme ich Bi-Word mittlerweile. Kennt ihr den?
Ich habe Writeroom, ja.
Ja, die nehmen sich ja alle nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Ich finde, obwohl Writeroom, welcher war denn das? Ich glaube, ich habe tatsächlich auch einige ausprobiert, bevor ich bei dem Minimalistischen, also der...
Na, Writeroom sieht halt so aus, irgendwie. Also der ist jetzt gerade nicht konfiguriert auf dem Mac, weil ich den hier noch nie benutzt habe.
Also ich habe hier dieses Bi-Word, ich glaube, der geht vom Preis her so halbwegs. Ich habe eine riesengroße Schrift angestellt. Ich habe Minion Pro, das ist eine wirklich geile Typo, die ich gerne auch auf dem iPhone hätte. Und in 24 Punkten, also der Text, den ich schreibe, der sieht sofort auch richtig toll gesetzt aus und so. Ich finde, so was macht echt mal...
Ja, da gibt es ja einige, ne?
Wobei das hat leider echt unter Leinen gelitten. Die haben jetzt Leinen-Kompatibilität hergestellt. Die hatten vorher schon Fullscreen-Modus. Und der Fullscreen-Modus war einfach so, solange es im Vordergrund war, war das App... Jetzt habe ich mich bestimmt wieder geschlagen. Dem App sein. Solange die im Vordergrund war, war die Fullscreen, wenn man wollte, und sobald man... Sobald sie im Hintergrund war, ist sie auf normales Fensterformat zurechtgeschrumpft. Was eigentlich total geil ist. Wenn du eigentlich tippen willst, dann willst du mal kurz was nachschlagen, dann siehst du noch dein Dokument nebenbei, neben deinem Browserfenster, und sobald sie am Vordergrund ist, ist es wieder Fullscreen. Ja, mit Line ist das jetzt natürlich tot, weil sie jetzt so volle Line-Kompatibilität haben, aber darüber hinaus ist es wirklich nach wie vor ein sehr schöner Editor, ich finde.
Da fällt mir ein, sagen wir mal, dieses eine Programm, womit man, so ein kleines Utility, da komm ich grad nicht auf den Namen, womit man seine Fenster nach so einem Raster platzieren kann, also du hast so ein... Da gab es aber noch ein anderes.
Also ich, es gab da noch ein anderes, ich bin da relativ...
Also es gab zwei von diesen, du hast halt so ein Raster-Overlay und kannst sagen, dieses Fenster soll jetzt... Ja, ne, genau.
Und dann kann ich das hier so, kann ich hier so dieses Raster nehmen, kannst das aufziehen und dann kann ich es so aufnehmen.
Genau, und davon gab es noch ein anderes und wie heißt das andere?
Also das hier habe ich Moom, das ist schon gar nicht so verkehrt.
Divi, Divi war es, genau.
Das gucke ich mir auch nochmal an, weil mit Moom bin ich nämlich nicht so 100% glücklich.
Genau, Divi war das, was ich mir nämlich auch nochmal angucken wollte. Das habe ich nämlich letztens auch bei einem Kollegen gesehen und irgendwie hat er das auch mit so einer Leichtigkeit benutzen bei einer Präsentation, weil eben Flink die... Die Fenster zusammen geschoben hat. Und irgendwie sah das ganz pfiffig aus. Ich werde das nochmal probieren, glaube ich. Na, du unterteilst sozusagen dein Desktop in beliebig viele Quadranten. Und jetzt hast du dein Terminal und kannst sagen, mit so wenigen Klicks oder Shortcuts, wie... Zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt zwei Fenster genau aufteilen willst nebeneinander und maximal den Platz ausnutzen willst, dann kannst du das eben mit diesem Tool machen. Und hast dann irgendwie deine Quadranten-Aufteilung und sagst jetzt hier, du kriegst 50% und der andere 50% und dann ist dein Screen komplett voll. Sie legen perfekt nebeneinander, überlappen sich nicht und...
Also was ich da...
Genau, machen wir diesen Screencast an, da sieht man das relativ zügig, höchstwahrscheinlich.
Also was ich relativ gut finde dafür ist, das macht so diese Windows-7-Gesten nach. Und zwar muss ich jetzt nochmal nachgucken, wie das heißt. Das glaub ich, wenn du das nach oben ziehst, an den oberen Bildschirmrand, dann siehst du hier so eine gestrichelte Linie. Und es geht über den ganzen Bildschirm. Und wenn du das an den linken Bildschirmrand ziehst, dann macht er den linken Bildschirmrand, an den rechten Bildschirmrand den rechten Bildschirmrand. Wenn man da jetzt noch die Größe einstellen könnte, dass man so sagen könnte, zum Beispiel 2 Drittel, 1 Drittel oder 3 Viertel, 1 Viertel, dann wär ich total glücklich damit, weil diese Gesten, die so ein Fenster mal eben rasch an den rechten oder linken Bildschirmrand schmeißen, ist eigentlich schnell gemacht. Cinch? Ich glaub, das heißt wieder Kabelanschluss.
Also so funktioniert das. Du kannst jetzt hier schön dir mal eben die Fenster so hin dirigieren, wie du das haben willst. Wie ihr so als Fenster-Messis, ne, das, äh, eigentlich finde ich das gar nicht schlecht. Und dann gibt's das eben noch mit Shortcuts. Und der hat da eben auch so mal eben schnell einen Terminal, mal eben schnell einen Browser nebeneinander und das war so Schnick Schnack Schnuck.
Schnick Schnack Schnuck.
Genau.
War das nicht mal so ein Trinkspiel?
So Leute, heute machen wir mal nicht so eine lange Sendung. Ich muss nämlich morgen nach Schweden.
Cinch mit C vorne C-I-N-C-H heißt das.
Das heißt, du fährst tatsächlich und fliegst nicht?
Doch, ich fliege. Ich fliege nach Kopenhagen und dann fahr ich nach Malmö.
Und dann beschwert er sich bei den Flatterjungs, dass wir zu wenig geflattert werden.
Genau.
Genau. Nee, aber die werde ich da mal besuchen und bin schon ganz gespannt. Auf die ganze Truppe.
Aber hast du die nicht schon ein paar Mal...
Kennst du die nicht, ja genau.
Ja, ja, ich kenn einige davon ein bisschen besser, aber ich kenn nicht so die ganze Truppe und ist ja auch mal was ganz anderes, ob die nun irgendwie gerade mal Auslauf haben oder ob die da quasi in ihrem Work-Mode sind.
Das stimmt. Naja, also ich muss jetzt auch nicht so lange. Wir haben ja eh eigentlich auch keine Themen.
Ne, sieht ganz so aus. Ich schau nochmal, wir könnten uns noch die Haare raufen, was denn mit dem iPhone 5 kommt, aber da gibt es ja nicht deutlich mehr Erkenntnisse als beim letzten Mal und von daher sind wir eigentlich kein Schritt weiter.
Doch, ein kleines Detail hätte ich da eventuell, und zwar, was ich glaube, es wird einfach, es wird ein billiges iPhone 5 geben. Also meine noch, darauf lege ich mich noch.
Ah, und es gibt eine neue Version von Minecraft. Ich hab's ja gleich mal wieder ein bisschen gespielt, nachdem ich echt lange Pause hatte und es hat Adventure Mode auch gleich wieder ein bisschen Spaß gemacht. Hab ich mir eine schöne Zombie-Falle gebaut.
Echt?
Und ein paar tüchtige Stollen durchs Gelände getrieben.
Ach ja, und ich kriege ja tausend Leute, weisen mich ja, ist das Kalenderthema nochmal kurz aufgreifer, aber so viele Leute schicken mir die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Links auf irgendwelche iOS-Apps, wo angeblich irgendwas richtig gelöst wäre, beziehungsweise, was noch schlimmer ist, diese ganzen Debugging-Optionen, die es bei iCal so gibt, so Hidden Features, die man so einschalten kann. All das löst das Problem nicht, was ich beklagt habe. Also der letzte Ding war, dass man bei iCal so ein Debugged-Menü einschalten kann, wo dann so Hidden Features drin sind. Unter anderem kannst du halt die Wochenansicht auf zwei Wochen oder auf drei Wochen expandieren. Das führt aber dann dazu, dass anstatt auf eine Woche schaust du halt dann auf zwei Wochen, aber alle hintereinander. Also von links nach rechts sozusagen die Tage. Das war ja nicht das, wovon ich geredet habe. Wovon ich rede ist eine Woche pro Zeile, aber smooth scrolling.
Kann man denn die Sidebar wieder einschalten? Weiches Rollen. Abrollen.
Abrollen.
Das ist eigentlich viel schöner als scrollen.
Ja, klingt furchtbar, ne?
Weiches Abrollen.
Früher war scroll noch was magisches. Hier ist a scroll of mail for you. Ja, so hieß das in Nethack. Ja, aber auch dieses großartige Spiel. Wisst ihr schon? Das erste vollvernetzte Dungeon-Game mit Ascii-Grafik. Wenn du während des Spiels Mail bekommen hast, kam ein Boote ins Spiel hinein und sprach dich an. Es kam kein Monster, sondern dieser Boote und meinte, hier ist a scroll of mail for you. Du musstest Nethack gar nicht verlassen, um deine Mail zu checken. Das Spiel hat es dir dann einfach selbst mitgeteilt.
Kannst du dann auch antworten, Nethack?
Du konntest dann dein Mail-Programm launchen.
Irgendwas wollte ich ja noch fragen, aber jetzt habe ich es doch wieder vergessen.
Mit dem Kalender noch?
Ja, die Sidebar. Kann man die Sidebar einschalten über das Debug-Menü?
Sidebar?
Ja, ich will da dieses Kalender auswählen, links oben in dieser komischen Kalenderblase. Das macht alles überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Ich hätte gerne die Sidebar wieder auch.
Ach so, dass man so rechts einfach so, dass nicht alles so Overlay-mäßig angezeigt wird.
Ja, links einfach die Sidebar zum Kalender auswählen.
Das I-Calendar wird echt immer schlechter. Ich guck halt mal, ob da irgendwie sowas zu sehen ist.
Wie Adobe-Programme?
Ja, es macht Sorge. Ich meine auch, das Adressbuch sieht jetzt ja auch so komisch aus.
Das sieht echt furchtbar aus.
Jetzt, ich bedarf das auch nicht.
Vor allen Dingen, warum kann man an smarte Gruppen, also es gibt ja diese Smart Groups, die sich automatisch zusammenstellen, warum kann man an die nicht eine Mail schreiben, einfach indem man oben die Smart, ich hab jetzt an die ganze Firma, bin das Smart.
Bist du jetzt bei Mail oder bei iCloud?
Na, bei Mail und Adressbuch. Also ich hab im Adressbuch mit allen Firmenmitgliedern, indem ich da gesagt habe, hey, wir hatten hier nextbigsink.com in seiner E-Mail-Adresse, sind alles Firmenmitarbeiter.
Das sind aber drei oder nicht?
Ja, das sind nicht viele. Aber ich meine, will man jetzt jedes Mal alle Namen tippen oder will man einmal schreiben, fertig. Und wer das im Namen hat, der ist in einer Firma und dann kann ich, dachte ich jetzt in Mail, könnte ich dann einfach eingeben den Namen der Gruppe und dann macht er das schon für mich? Nein, macht er nicht. Warum macht er das nicht? Die blöde Sau. Kann man jemandem im Adressbuch sagen, dass er eine blöde Sau ist? Wobei ich ja das neue Mail in Leyen sehr mag. Das ist ja...
Das nicht, deswegen weiß ich es gar nicht.
Das ist auf jeden Fall mal wieder ein Versuch wert. Ich war ja ein großer Mailhasser geworden im Laufe der Zeit, weil es so unglaublich viele Features nicht besaß und ich es nur noch furchtbar fand. Und war froher glücklicher Sparrow Nutzer, aber jetzt seit Leyen bin ich dann doch wieder bei Mail gelandet.
Also die Sidebar kann man nicht im Debug-Menü einschalten.
Nee, habe ich auch nicht gefunden, ja.
Ach, es gibt Top Secret.
Use iPad Style. Ist denn das iPad-Style wie Bentley Out?
Ja, das ist nicht so, wie man sich das denkt, wie es ist. Also es ist schon richtig, dass dieses Menü verborgen ist. Das hilft einfach überhaupt nicht weiter.
Es ist schlecht, iCal ist schlecht. Hört doch jetzt endlich mal zu, Apple. Und uns hat ihr ein Vögelchen gezwitschert, ist zwar mit 10.7.2, was demnächst kommt. Eigentlich hat Max uns das gezwitschert.
Vögelchen, Vogel oder was?
Du twitterst auf jeden Fall. Das hat zwar viele Bugs gefixt werden, aber iCal sieht da immer noch genauso aus.
Ich glaube, das wird jetzt auch erstmal so bleiben.
Scheiße, zwei Jahre jetzt in diesem Dreck.
Das war Steve's letzter Wunsch und das bleibt jetzt auch so.
Wenn ich Object-C coden könnte.
Also das ist die hoffnungsvolle Sichtweise, dass das sein letzter Wunsch war.
iCal-Scheiße zu machen?
Ach du meinst, die Alternative dazu ist, dass er...
Das ist die erste Erosion.
Dass er merkte, ich hab's nicht mehr unter Kontrolle, ich glaub ich geh mal schnell. iCal-Kill-Steve.
Auf Deutsch bitte.
Der E-Kalender hat Steve getötet. Stefan getötet.
Nein, Stefan getötet.
Wir müssen raus hier.
Unbedingt müssen wir raus.
Es ist 22 Uhr, 22 und 22 Sekunden.
Genau. Raus, Mädels. Wir machen heute mal eine ganz knuffige, kurze, überschaubare Sendung. Warum auch nicht?
Heute mal nicht vorm Rechner einschlafen.
Ja, genau. Wir könnten aber auch was anderes machen.
Ein bisschen um die Freundinnen kümmern.
Ja, genau.
Es ist ja auch Montag.
Genau. Das kommt noch dazu.
Ruhetag.
Nächste Terminfindung wird knifflig.
Wie immer.
Ich hoffe, dass es danach dann nicht mehr so knifflig ist.
Das behauptest du jetzt auch schon seit einem halben Jahr.
Ja, das stimmt.
Was soll ich machen?
So, hab ich irgendwas übersehen? Haben wir noch ein letztes Wort?
Meine Freundin will keinen Sex, weil Alkohol so hässlich ist. Steht da im Chat. Steht da im Chat.
Das kann ja jeder sagen, Max.
Hast du doch vorhin erzählt?
Ja.
Das war's.
Und wir sind jetzt mal weg.
Und das nächste Mal ist er bestimmt wieder dabei. Oder? Ja.
Ich hoffe doch.
Und ZFS.
Dann gibt's endlich mal... Ja, hab ich voll grad gesagt.
Genau, dann reden wir nochmal wieder.
Tschüss.
Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.